The joe rogan experience by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day,
fresh off the road.
Sturgill Simpson.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thanks for doing this man.
I really appreciate it.
And Yeah,
man,
you kidding me?
Yeah,
I'm here.
You're here.
I,
you know,
I had heard about your music from several people online.
I don't remember who made me take the plunge and download your shit.
Like a bunch of people would recommended you.
I had shooter Jennings on and along those lines,
like people said like,
hey man,
if you really dig shooter Jennings,
you have a checkout Sturgill Simpson.
Right?
And so somewhere along the line I downloaded,
um,
I think it was a well downloaded two cds,
but the,
uh,
turtles all the way down song,
that was the first song I heard.
I was like,
Oh shit,
this guy's doing something unusual.
You doing some psychedelic country music,
man,
you're,
you're mixing shit up in a very bizarre way.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
just,
I don't know.
I grew up listening to everything.
So,
but,
uh,
for whatever reason,
if I go to write or sing a song,
I can only do one of two things and that's either the same country or bluegrass
is what primarily grew up on.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
the first record I did was a very traditional country record in terms of some
magical lyrical elements.
And uh,
so this is before it was true,
I just,
I reached a point where it was like,
um,
I'm very happily married,
I'm sober,
you know,
for the longest period.
And just so drinking songs and heartache and all that wasn't something that I
was particularly very excited about tackling.
And again,
you know.
Right.
Do you feel like you have to hit certain themes if you're doing country music
because it just sort of falls into that?
It seems to be somewhat self restricting and low is,
it hasn't evolved very much even since,
you know,
60s or 70s right over there was,
there was periods that are very dated now,
like seventies and eighties country.
You can hear the production values and it just,
there's nothing tying,
you know,
even some of the timeless,
timeless singers that ever they've ever played.
The music,
the records that they made got subjected to these really bad tastes choices.
Right.
And it just doesn't stand up.
Um,
so I dunno,
date my producer is a really close friend of mine,
Dave Cobb,
who actually did shooters first couple of records.
Um,
she was a buddy.
He's a good dude.
Very,
very sweet.
Such a cool guy to hang out with too.
Yes,
I'm David and just Kinda,
you know,
I came to Nashville about four years ago,
almost five now I guess.
And I just,
I knew more than anything what I didn't want to do.
And um,
I met with Dave shooter actually I think told him one night we were all at a
Billy Joe shaver concert.
I didn't know any of those guys.
And they were sitting upstairs.
It was like shooter and Jamey Johnson's mother,
cats and Dave.
And,
uh,
apparently shooting was like,
hey man,
you see that guy right there and it tastes like a sleek suppose fucking country
singer in Nashville.
So the next day somehow my manager got an email from Dave and we had lunch and I
was like,
all right,
he's from Georgia.
We both love the same records growing up.
I just Kinda feel like I know this dude,
I can work with this guy.
Right.
And there was nobody in there cause I paid for both albums entirely by myself or
like dug a big giant hole of debt.
Wow.
And then how much does it cost to put on an album?
The first one?
Um,
I thought when I was doing it,
this may very well be the only time I ever get to do this,
you know?
Right.
And I wanted something that I could be proud of.
That's something my family can be proud of for once.
You know what I mean?
It just,
I knew it had to be right and I couldn't compromise in any way.
And um,
there was a certain sound we were after.
So Dave,
he said,
well,
let's just get the guys that played on those old records and went,
yeah,
let's fucking,
let's just do that.
I didn't know how the game works.
Right,
right.
So then I'm looking up and next thing I know when we were a studio,
it was like,
this guy's like pig Robbins who pretty much invented country piano.
He played on,
let me get started.
The first session was with George Jones on white lightning.
And
what a fucking name.
Yeah.
He's going to be played with blonde on blonde.
He's this old blind pig.
Robbins pig.
Hargis pig Robbins fucking name cut.
That's an American name.
You could probably be English to English
pink cause he,
I mean he toured with everybody plays on Patsy Cline records and bow.
Wow.
I knew when those sessions ended,
I knew that I had absolutely done my best cause I had to,
you know,
these guys would just bust your balls in a second,
you know?
And uh,
so we,
I feel like we sort of cleared my throat with that one.
And then Lo and behold,
a year later,
I found myself in a position where I was going to get to make another record.
He was like,
all right,
well maybe I'll,
this one will be a little bit more selfish or self was over for me.
So we,
Dave and I incorporated a lot of other elements of,
I guess Sonic Temple and you don't normally hear in most country music.
And they gave me the freedom to kind of go out there with the themes as well.
So,
um,
I was doing a lot of reading at the time.
Um,
always have like weird shit,
you know?
Uh,
we'll get there,
but,
uh,
I don't know me,
it was the most,
the most truly inspirational group of songs I feel like I've ever written
because it was just from a such a fresh place.
Okay.
You know,
maybe that's why the record's done.
It's very unique,
you know,
it's very unique in that it has a lot of country sound to it.
But I like the turtles all the way down.
Song me,
who the fuck is doing songs about mind expanding consciousness,
expanding drugs in country music.
I mean that's just not being done,
but it's still like really good country music.
Like I,
I'm like a lot of country music,
you know,
then the eye,
even songs that are even like a song that's sort of a classic song with all
those themes that you talked about before,
like drinking a heartache.
If it's well done,
I still really like it,
you know?
Absolutely.
No,
I mean if it's,
if it's,
if it's pure
yeah.
And honest and has great music,
I just didn't feel like I had anything to offer there.
Yeah.
The sound though is a,
I think people are starting to accept that but not,
not even starting to accept,
but sort of for a long time country got classified amongst a lot of young people
as being like a dumb kind of music,
you know,
and unfairly so.
And I think that as some young people started getting into some of the other
country,
like getting into some Johnny Cash songs for instance,
you know,
he started going,
oh this is country to,
okay well you can't say Johnny Cash songs are dumb.
You just can't.
I mean,
they were just,
he had too much crazy shit going on in those songs.
You know,
it's undeniable.
He moves a lot going on in between the lines.
There's a lot going on in a boy named sue.
I mean,
just think about that song.
I mean he had some great fucking songs and then he did the highway men.
And that was an interesting song to like that thing that he did with Willie
Nelson and uh,
who,
who else was it?
Was it the Christopher?
So yeah,
it was a Wayland and they did this,
this crazy song about reincarnation that to this day,
if you never heard it,
um,
go,
go find that song.
The highway men and uh,
it's uh,
this wheelie wild song cause it's all dif different versus sung by different
Kyle.
Like willy will sing one verse and then Johnny comes in.
I fly a star ship.
Oh my God,
that's a good fucking song.
It's just,
whew.
Well,
you know,
weirdly it and it's,
it's so,
it's funny to me that the country has this really rigid perception by the public
doesn't mean all.
If you look back at any of the really good,
great country singer,
they were all bat shit.
You know what I mean?
It was just like someone who was colorful,
weird characters to ever walk through American history,
you know?
So I mean it,
for me,
it's not really much of a stretch.
I didn't feel like I was really going out there too far.
You know what it is,
man?
It's south FISM.
It's like racism towards the south.
It's like thinking that anybody who has a southern accent,
it's got to be a moron.
Thank you to anybody who's singing country songs.
They've,
they've got to suck.
That's it's what it is.
It's an urban form of classism.
Like we,
you look at that style of music and they automatically,
some people did for a while,
but I think guys like shooter,
guys like you,
you're,
you guys are opening up when honey honey band does a lot of country type sound.
Uh,
I think a lot of people are opening up people's ideas of what that sound really
is.
And you hear a great song.
It's like God damn it.
That's a great song.
It doesn't matter if they've got a banjo playing in the background.
You can't tell me that song didn't fuck you up.
You know,
I think,
I think people are starting to realize like there's,
it's just good
man.
There's just good,
there's good disco songs,
man.
Okay.
You ever heard kiss?
I was made for loving you to good goddamn disco song.
I don't give a fuck what anybody says.
I'm not a kiss hater man.
I love the monkeys.
When I was a kid,
dude,
the monkeys had some good fucking songs.
I don't care if they put a deal together.
Diamond wrote half that shit.
Did he really?
Yeah.
That's one of the songs are so fucking great,
man.
Oh Wow.
That makes a lot of sense.
Wow,
that's incredible.
I like Neil diamond songs.
I set it.
I fucking said it.
I don't care what he's doing.
What his hair.
I'd like a god Damn Neil diamond song any day.
Yeah man,
it goes a genius.
There's,
and I think when you expand your horizon,
sort of open up your ideas of musical appreciation.
Like I've tried really hard with a lot of stuff and it just can't catch like
every few months or so.
I try with Chaz,
I'll throw some cold train on and I'll be able to compete BBB,
BBB [inaudible] I'll be in my car and then five minutes in I fucking snap.
I just can't take it anymore and throw some kid rock auto.
So just to turn it the other way,
I just can't do it.
It's probably the only music I never got into like like hillbilly jazz,
but I don't like,
I don't know Charles Mingus and guys like that.
Maybe I can listen,
but even in brief doses,
cause I just prefer like a melody,
you know?
Yeah.
I was like a song,
good song.
I think one thing that it's good for like jazz at a bar,
like if you're having a couple drinks and some jazz is playing in the
background,
it's not like a very recognizable song.
It's just interesting music.
It's interesting like background music.
But as far as it being my main focal point,
you know,
not really,
maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe.
Maybe I need to find the right stuff.
What are you listening to?
I tried a bunch of different shit.
Thelonious monk.
I've tried some cold train.
I've tried obviously the,
they're great musicians.
I mean there's no denying they have skill,
but it just doesn't gripped me in any way.
I don't know what it is you ever a bitches brew but Miles Davis,
right?
Killer.
Pretty killer.
Um,
I can do that.
Yeah.
I mean there's some rifts that I really enjoy for a lump,
but I can't like sit like I can sit and listen to the same Leonard Skinner he
album maybe like three times in a row,
you know?
But it's very hard for me to listen to the same jazz stuff over and over and
over again.
I just,
I dunno,
whatever it is,
I'm missing it.
And Woody Allen's got it and I'm missing it.
You know,
there's,
there's a saying,
you know,
you're going to go play jazz until the money runs out.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Well,
we were in a,
just in Philadelphia,
I was in Philly on Friday night and we passed by the jazz bar and we thought,
man,
we should go after the show.
Could fucking see some jazz.
Never did it.
No,
no.
We thought about it.
It's one of those things I would stash.
I've never said that because there's some jazz.
So how did you get into staying in country music?
Was that what you've always sang or did you do fuck around with other forms of
music first?
Oh yeah.
Well,
actually I didn't really have a choice.
Both my
grandfathers played,
um,
you know,
well,
actually we were in eastern Kentucky where I'm originally from.
Everybody's really plays music,
but it's,
it's what you do after work,
you know?
Yeah.
My mom's brother,
like all his friends,
they had this house and they just as these two twin brothers and they,
both of them never married,
so they turned their house into a fucking practice space and they just had this
pa and lights and shit.
The state set up all the time on it.
And uh,
so I was real young kid and I'd go over there.
I always played guitar and uh,
yeah,
I mean,
before I even really knew anything about music or songwriting,
I think I was learning how to play in a band just from hanging out with those
guys.
But yeah,
it was never encouraged.
It was there were like,
you don't think,
oh,
I can do this for a living,
if that makes sense.
Right.
You just do it because everybody's doing it.
And nobody thinks they're going to leave that situation or,
or for many other reasons.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
it is what it is,
but so yeah,
Dad's dad was a big bluegrass guy,
played mandolin and just shoved that shit down my throat.
I mean,
repeatedly until I accepted it.
And then moms,
my other grandfather,
he was like a big Merle Haggard,
Marty Hart,
Robin's guy and had an old Gibson,
a very beautiful voice.
Um,
he,
he probably more than anybody,
we'd watch he hall and Shit when I was a kid and TNN and he kind of tell me
which of the guys were actually play in and the ones that were just holding a
guitar is a prop.
Oh Wow.
You know,
and like Roy Clark and Jerry Reed and guys like they're cute.
Yeah.
I knew by the time I was five,
like I don't give a fuck,
but anything else ever.
Wow.
I gotta to drop task old in third grade at the same result.
Um,
that's interesting.
So you kind of groomed in the music sense,
but not maybe in becoming a professional,
right.
Yeah.
Without knowing it may be.
Um,
because I'd never really played in mini vans.
but yeah,
I had an older cousin Mike too.
He was like six or seven years older than me,
so you know,
and just be older teenage neighbors with Chevy Novas and shit,
listening to guns and roses when you're in fifth grade and the,
but Mike Really,
I remember very vividly,
one weekend we'd go up to visit,
they had a form Ohio and uh,
I was probably in fourth or fifth grade and he,
he said,
I remember he knew I was really into music.
I was playing guitar and he's like,
what are you listening to?
And I don't know,
I mean it's probably wasn't the monkeys or something.
And he took me his bedroom and he had one of those like tower stereo systems
with the glass door and the super headphones.
And he sent me and CD's had just come out,
you know,
this is like 87,
88,
I don't know.
And uh,
he just had this already had this fucking mountain of cds and he's like here.
And he was like Zeppelin box set and cream and Hendrix and humble pie and
traffic and all these bands.
I mean,
it was like a fucking bomb just went off in my head.
That was it.
I was done.
My,
what?
My life was ruined.
I very clearly remember the transition between records and cds.
I remember the first
very first cds showing up with a record store because kids today probably don't
even appreciate it because of the last 10 years of the Internet is dominated
digital downloads ever since Napster came along and then iTunes and everybody
knows how to get shit online and there's no record stores in the morning.
Obviously there's a few,
but I mean it used to be like a local community spot.
Well I lived in Newton,
Massachusetts and we used to go down to this place that was right across the
street from a place that I worked at.
I worked at this ice cream place called Newport creamery.
Uh,
we made hamburgers or wash dishes and do all that shit.
And the across the street from Newport creamery was the record store at all.
Kids would go there after school.
So our own cultural,
it was the only like output to like the,
the rock and roll of the world.
But you want to,
every week a new record came out.
Yes.
And I remember when the cds came out,
everybody's like,
what is this?
Right?
What?
Off I look and it's got a rainbow in it.
If you wiggle it,
it makes rainbows,
all the digital thing.
I think in a lot of ways it's great,
but I believe it almost entirely for
the downward spiral of,
you know,
the quality of music in the 70s.
I mean,
if you,
if you've got a record deal,
you had to be bad.
The fuck ass right.
There was no slop.
Right.
Pro Tools and shit to go in and make everybody.
Yeah.
Right.
Actually was a quote,
pig said this too.
He's like,
you know what they used before pro tools like fucking pros,
so got named peg would say,
that's awesome.
Yeah.
They used to have to,
you know,
the sound was a different sound too,
right?
I mean,
the people that are real,
I'm vinyl heads.
They'll tell you I'm,
I don't recognize it.
Um,
I'm not educated.
Yeah.
I mean I'm a pretty good,
okay.
I'm an audio file.
Fucking sorry.
Super Geek about it.
Yeah.
I've never gotten into it.
I should,
I should really get,
get a record player and a Marin's really into that shit.
He keeps stacks of them at home.
He listens to them,
they meticulously clean them and put them down.
You have to have the right ear phones and I guess it's got like,
what is this sound is different because I don't listen to that.
I think it's just,
there's a warmth to it,
a warmth.
Um,
everything just sounds really settled and cohesive.
Whereas digital,
I hear the separation specialist area,
you can just hear,
it's almost like you're sitting with the mixing board and you just like some
asshole decided that guitar needed to be like a hard two o'clock right there.
But in a vinyl it just kind of seems more three dimensional.
Like it's coming from around you,
I feel like.
Wow.
So you can sort of hear the different tracks.
Oh yeah.
You know,
I,
maybe I'm just don't have a fucking ear for music.
Maybe.
That makes sense.
Some of my,
my choice,
you've got to know you're listening for,
is that what it is?
Yeah.
Well you weren't here when we had Russell Peters on Russell Peters is a standup
comic friend of mine.
Very funny guy.
And he's also a DJ.
And uh,
we were playing some songs and he could pick out was a rap song and he could
pick out what the samples were from.
And I was like,
what?
How do you hear that?
Like I didn't even,
he's like,
yeah,
you can hear right here.
She did it to do,
did it,
did you like that would be bump up law firm,
you know,
1984.
And I was like,
well I don't,
I don't know how the fuck you just did that.
I trust you,
but I don't know how the fuck you just did that.
He's got a separate knowledge base of old music to reference from.
But yeah,
his,
his is all old hip hop stuff.
He's,
he loves like old hip hop stuff.
So the thing about the record stores that people loved was that it was like,
uh,
like a sort of like,
because we didn't have the internet,
you would go there and it was like you would see like these,
it was on like a big piece of paper.
Like Holy Shit,
here's,
you know,
here's the new Bruce Springsteen album.
I think it's right there.
And you see,
oh wow.
It's like,
this is what he made is what we've been doing for the past year.
Bruce has been writing all these songs and Pam,
here we go.
Have,
you didn't have fucking youtube,
you didn't have,
you know,
I think that's the worst thing that ever happened is now everything's so
accessible in the kids' attention span is so short.
They'll never know that experience to sit down and listen to the album all the
way through and then just fucking obsess about it.
And then,
you know,
hold that physical thing that sleeve in your hand.
Just like,
what the fuck are these guys doing?
Like,
like they got a secret laboratory.
I don't think there's like a stout or something I don't know about.
Yeah.
And mystery,
I guess was the most important element.
Rocker and let's just fucking gone,
do you remember when the Wall came out?
No,
I wasn't born in 78.
I mean I remember watching it way too young,
but uh,
I was in high school when I found out about the wall,
so it was after the wall come out.
But I remember sitting there with my friend and we had like,
uh,
like the headphone Jack thing plugged in so you could have two headphones both
listening to it and you the how's everything like ties in together,
it seems so beyond human reach like that.
These guys figured out how to do all this,
that they put these amazing songs and they just sort of flow into each other.
Like some wild ride you're on or like dark side of the moon.
Very similar.
You know,
like the,
the song they was linked with the album,
they always link up to a,
the wizard of Oz.
The mean that album just everything just flows together in this crazy way.
It did feel like they were in a lab somewhere.
Well,
Marvin Gaye would do that a lot too.
A Willie Nelson did a lot of concept record.
They call it song cycle where you just,
you don't ever feel like there's an actual pause anywhere in the albums.
It was just this one cohesive work.
Wow.
Um,
and that does take time and plan.
We did a little bit of a metal modern.
We're kind of,
you know,
pink Floyd and some other albums were definitely reference while we were,
we were cutting that shit towards the end.
When you first decided that you were going to be a professional country music
singer,
did you decide slowly and gradually or did you just fucking dive in?
I didn't,
I only started my
career or attempting to have a career about four years ago really.
And I never would have done it to be completely honest.
My,
it was really my wife's side.
Yeah.
Um,
so she's the one that really kind of encouraged me to go for it.
And,
uh,
cause I,
you know,
I just,
there's always something I did as a hobbyist and would write and play and I get
a lot of grief from friends,
especially in my twenties.
Really?
Why aren't you out?
You know what I mean?
This is,
you should be doing something because we go to shows at clubs and they'd be
like,
this is fun.
Cool.
We just,
we'd rather be at homeless in the you play,
you know?
And uh,
I just,
I don't know why I never thought,
okay,
what's it like the limitations of your environment,
maybe the people that you were moved to Nashville once in 2006 I went down
because you know,
you can play in local bands and you can,
you know,
if that's what you want out of it,
that's great.
And there's a lot of people that do that.
I don't know,
on a hobbyist level,
you,
it's what,
you know,
like I said,
it's what you do after work.
And for me that just never felt rewarding enough,
you know?
And I never felt like I was giving everything I could to it.
Right.
And it's very frustrating place and up.
And I ended up putting it down a lot of times because of that,
because it just,
I felt like it was bringing me more heartache than it was.
Uh,
right.
Um,
so I,
you know,
took jobs and work normal jobs and that was out working in railroad job in Utah
for about almost four years.
And my wife was out there with me,
I guess for whatever reason,
from dealing with the stress of that.
And I didn't realize at the time I wasn't,
yeah,
okay.
Fulfilling my fucking purpose,
Joe Rogan.
You know what I mean?
She kind of recognized that and I started writing a lot as a,
as a result of dealing with the stress from,
from my job and playing at home.
And She just kind of told me,
when you saw,
you know,
you don't suck at this.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
you know,
you're going to wake up at 40
and no,
you never fucking try it.
And then I'm stuck with you're miserable ass.
We sold everything and,
and literally mean she and I and our dog and a Ford Bronco drove to Nashville.
And Wow.
That was like four years ago.
So,
and I,
you know,
no,
I was older.
I was clean.
I was,
I was focused.
I had,
I had purpose.
So I just,
the first year,
you know,
you kind of got to get the lay of the land and it's,
it's a hustle.
It's a total shark tank.
I just decided I wasn't gonna have anything to do with that shit.
I'm,
I'm not a social guy.
I don't go to bars and clubs and things like that.
And so what is it like,
man?
Yeah,
well there's so many facets to it.
Okay.
You know,
depending on what the industry,
there's so many sides of the industry and you that people fall into and most,
and I'd say the bulk majority of it is,
is complete and total shameless opportunists.
Hmm.
Um,
then the musicians come and everybody,
and I'm,
you know,
thinking about musicians were lazy as fuck and nobody really wants to work.
So you get all these guys,
he's side players are looking for songwriters to get gigs supporting or backing
up.
Then they weren't like half the door.
What you get paid for their services because they don't want to wait tables and
there's guys that are really good and earn that money.
Okay.
Um,
and then there's the side of it,
but it just really feels like to me the first time I feel like everybody I met
one,
it's like literally,
hey man,
how's it going?
What can you do for me?
And while they're talking to you,
they're looking over your shoulder to see who else they should solely talking to
is very Hollywood.
Like it's getting more and more.
Yeah.
So cause that would just cause the money thing.
Cause there's money in country.
Well there's
a lot of fucking money.
Really.
That's the only thing still selling cds.
That's why the labels are still still gutsy.
Need buyers for his old school something last night there's going to be no
platinum albums this year for the night,
for the first time.
I mean now if you have a hit record,
you drop an album on a major label.
If you sell 200,000 copies in a week,
that's a success.
10 years ago,
if you sold 200,000 copies the first week they had a dropped your ass and then
Kratom you know,
so the whole thing is just,
it really is the wild west when the Internet and social media,
um,
it,
it affords guys like me and a lot of other people like me doing what I'm doing.
The opportunity to reach people without having to
go down certain avenues I guess.
And country didn't used to be like that,
like Nashville used to be like,
what?
What was it like?
It was know gatekeepers.
And um,
but when you,
when,
when exactly do you mean?
I mean before it became more Hollywood asks the way it is now,
has it always had an element of show business to it?
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
They do Taki real well and it's kind of,
um,
but it,
I wouldn't say there's a certain la element to Nashville that's this kind of
come on in the last two or three years more so.
Um,
it's very hip.
I blame that Hootie and the blowfish car when he crossed over.
Yeah.
When Doris got in a black guy who sings good country Charley Pride,
man.
Dammit.
I know,
but it's been a while.
Yeah,
that's true.
Darious snuck right in there and all those white people came running with them.
That's what happened.
He brought him in.
It's a very interesting
situation.
I don't,
it doesn't really,
the fakeness to it.
Yeah,
it's very,
it's very studied in effect.
Studying the effect is a prep way.
Describe it fakeness to me falling short again,
I just,
I,
you know,
a lot of journalists I've been baited,
I can't tell you how many times they want me to get like pulled into this
negative conversation and just bash and talk shit on it and,
and I could eat,
I could do that.
But you know,
there's,
there's so much negativity already.
I don't feel like
whatever this,
um,
opportunity is,
I don't want to use it for that.
Right.
Well,
you know what,
quite honestly,
the negative aspects of anything,
whether it's show business or you know,
Co standup comedy or music,
I don't think this isn't anything negative about talking about them.
I think the positive effect of talking about them is that young people recognize
that they're not crazy,
that they,
they sent something goofy about this and then it becomes like more clearly
defined what's goofy about it and it gives them a high standard to not set a
trap for themselves.
Like I know in comedy there's a thing that guys do when they first start out,
which really fucks you up.
You just trying to get laughs like you're saying things you don't even believe.
Right.
Cause you just hoping it would work because you just terrified cause you're on
stage.
And I think similarly in music you could
just start making stuff that you think like,
you know,
like one of those pros that writes those pop songs.
You know those guys,
I was weird dudes that just know how to like make something that clicks in but
there's no feeling to it
all.
They sit in cubicles.
Yeah.
Heaps of four and five shit,
I'm not kidding.
That's a reality.
Yeah,
go to work.
There's big goddamn difference between that.
And like someone who's writing shit,
like you're writing someone who's like writing shit that resonates.
It's,
I can tell no matter what your influences are in this life musically or even
while you're creating a song,
it's all filtering through your unique individual vision.
And that's entirely missing from all these like poppy things.
And that's like something that people connect with and some,
I mean look,
there's something personal about songs that,
you know,
the dude wrote it,
you know the guy singing it like,
like my friends and honey honey band,
they write all their shit.
So when they're singing it and they're,
they're sitting here in the studio singing it or you seen him on stage,
like that's their creation.
It's 100% and there's like a uniqueness to that that your music has that a lot
of like music that it's,
it hits like a different frequency as opposed to like a poppy frequency and,
and these people that are coming in that are just trying to exploit it and
monetize it,
they probably,
that doesn't register with them.
Or even if it does,
they don't give a shit because that's not where that is.
They're just worried about the quarterly report.
Very seldom to any of the people running labels actually know anything or give a
shit about music.
It's just really more,
that's really more of a recent development and a lot of them are run by very
young guys now like in their thirties cause the old,
the old Reus Kinda went out,
retired,
it kind of turned over and a lot of the dudes that were in la in the 80s making
all those awful hair metal band records,
those producers and engineers,
once that industry dried up,
a lot of them move in Nashville that he's turned on the radio today.
You'll find that a lot of that shit sounds exactly like a poison record.
There's a reason for that.
Wow,
that's interesting.
That formulaic way of creating it.
Making hits.
Yeah.
And you know,
and I think two or three decades ago,
they,
the,
the labels still offered up the other that you had all these great bands that
were making art because they knew they were going to sell a fuck ton of copies
and make their money back.
So they were willing to take the risk.
And now there's,
there's really no risk takers.
And I don't know if that's because of it,
some,
maybe there's a lack of visionaries
because the money's dried up.
It just,
they don't think they're just,
they're all sitting in their corner offices looking out the window wishing it
would go back to 1996 and twiddling their thumbs and pray into a dying business
model because they completely depended on radio for sale sales of singles and
cumulus and clear channel.
Pretty much all of it.
Completely lock that out to a very politically selected group of songs,
which somebody paid probably at least a million just to
get it in rotation.
Um,
you know,
they'll pay a million or $2 million to make a hit.
Um,
that's so crazy.
That's sad.
That's sad to hear.
It's a business.
It is a business,
but it's sad to hear.
It's just like flipping real estate or something.
Yeah.
Um,
so there's no artists development anymore.
So I,
you know,
luckily I didn't try to do this at 22 or 26 years.
Now I've worked real jobs when I was able to understand that the mechanical
aspect of it all,
and you know,
there's,
that's not the only way to do it anymore.
You can just kind of bypass around that.
It's a much longer,
harder road,
but,
but then again,
it's not,
but then because if he catch fire,
right,
you know,
just,
just spreads across the Internet.
It's much more rewarding road,
I can tell you that.
Oh fuck.
Yeah,
it's got to be,
I can only imagine.
I mean,
I would imagine that being stuck singing some songs that you don't believe in
and that,
that are not really good,
but everybody you know,
is really responding to,
and you have something inside you that you wished you could've got out,
but now you're trapped.
You know,
that's gotta suck,
I would imagine.
Do you remember when Garth Brooks came back with a different character?
Chris Gaines,
man.
Yeah.
Put the wig on.
There was nobody there to say,
hey,
maybe you shouldn't do this.
But he was surrounded by yes people.
You just know because somebody was like,
yeah,
that's,
that's fun.
That'll be cool.
Someone didn't say,
wait,
what?
Wait,
You're going to hold on you?
What are you gonna do?
You get to put a wig on and you're going to change your name,
but everybody's going to know it's you.
So what are you doing?
Are you playing the character now you're playing a character.
That's how art,
man.
Yeah,
you're a,
you're a goddamn superstar.
Shows these Helen some,
you know I got friends in low places,
sold a lot of fucking copies and what are you going to do now?
You're going to put a fucking look at him.
We get it.
He had hair across his face.
Remember that shit?
He grew a soul patch.
Like what the fuck was going on there?
It's his,
it's his filtered interpret.
I think he was going for like,
uh,
Ryan Adams.
He sorta thing.
I don't know.
I think he just straight went crazy.
I think that was fucking nuts.
That's,
that's very distinct possibility.
He blew a rod right there.
He's red lining is engine.
Look at those.
Okay,
thank,
thank.
That was blowing a rod in the engine and then from then on he kind of
disappeared.
You never hear about Garth Brooks anymore.
Oh,
he just came back.
Well he's gonna.
I mean he'll still do well he's got a lot of fucking hits,
but it's been a long time where Garth Brooks is in the public consciousness.
But meanwhile in the 1990s or whatever,
it was 80 I guess nineties early nineties when did he,
when was he just charged anti?
Yeah,
like early nineties and he just kinda came out of nowhere.
She Cam type knocked it right out.
It really all think a lot of stuff going on today is an absolute direct
byproduct.
It's still,
we're still getting the ripples of all that because at some point country music
turned into like a really Shitty van.
Halen con,
not David Lee
Roth.
No.
Sammy Hagar.
Hagar knew.
I knew what you were going to mean.
Come on,
man.
That's,
you know,
it's fascinating.
There's two or religion too.
I think that the original van Halen with David Lee Ross was the greatest bands
of all time,
but without a doubt,
running with the devil to this day,
it's like if I'm on the treadmill and I throw on running with the devil,
I'll crank that bitch up an extra couple of miles an hour.
Fuck it.
You know,
it's just one of those songs,
man.
But they did just as well with Sammy Hagar.
They really did it.
It might have done better.
They got more soccer moms.
Eh?
What happened commercially?
I think it took him even more.
It made them more accessible and we're fuck is that,
I don't know.
How does,
Aaron was my first concert ever.
My Dad took,
took me see van Halen with fifth grade.
Really fucking Eddie van Halen for,
you know,
for a fifth grader.
That's,
that's amazing.
And the fifth grade.
Yeah,
I think mine was the ninth grade and went to see the j Geils band.
J Geils band was huge back then.
Angel was a centerfold.
Loved stinks.
They were giant man.
Yolo deep cuts.
Yeah.
Giant in my highschool giant in 1981 or whatever the hell it was.
Where are you from?
Newton.
Well that's I,
that's where I went to high school.
I was born in New Jersey.
I grew up kind of all over the country.
Lived in San Francisco from age seven to 11 lived in Florida from 11 to 13
Boston from 13 to probably 2124 and then New York for a couple of years in
California.
So I'm from California now.
I'm more Californian than anything I've ever been in my life.
But I was placed at mass.
It's a fucking mess.
It's not the worst place though.
It's just as too many people.
If you could whittle California,
if you could whittle Los Angeles down to like one 10th of its size as far as
like population wise.
So just so you know,
if you ever go to Seattle,
I bet it was the shit.
I bet word his shift.
He's man.
I mean it was just,
it was the absolute shit.
It's just a matter of like inconvenience and overpopulation.
Like see,
Seattle has like lived in Seattle for a very few people.
That's how it kicked my ass.
Did it?
Oh yeah.
What was it?
The rain among other things rang,
did get rid of the rain is,
I think it was a direct contributor to a lot of the other problems people
acquire while they live in Seattle.
But the rain keeps people from moving there too.
This is a good thing about that Goddamn name.
It really is so beautiful.
Especially the summers.
It's,
I mean it's really hard to beat Seattle in the summertime.
It's just nine months of the most dismal.
I mean,
I remember like hanging my towel up to drivers,
taking a shower and you come in there two days later it'd be like fucking Lichen
growing on.
It's just a petri dish,
you know?
Yeah.
So much precipitation that you just,
people are jacked up on coffee or heroin all the time,
but I have friends that live in Seattle that will fucking defended to the death.
Like right now,
the Voodoo chicken is raising his fist and anger.
You wait till I get ahold of you.
He fucking moved there from Indiana,
my friend Voodoo chicken.
That's what his official stage name is.
And when he did that man,
like he liked it way better than Indiana and I'm like,
that's good,
that's good.
But if you ever lived in Los Angeles,
have you ever lived where it just doesn't fucking rain like we're babies.
We're used to just soak it in that side of every day.
Every day.
We don't have a 320 days a year.
About 370 we have extra days on days.
It tells it fucking rain.
It's a total drought.
I mean we're stealing water from the Colorado River or some shit.
I don't know how we keep everything hydrated until some super genius guy figures
out how to suck water out of the ocean.
The W you want to get some ocean front property about like 700 yards in because
within like three everybody's worried about the sea level rising.
All you have to do is figure out how to desalinate ocean water will drink that
shit.
We'll use that shit and our toilets.
We'll just start extra golf courses with that fucking Osha.
That'll just,
you won't be nothing.
Don't worry about that thing rising.
Oh,
you're worried about there'd be too much water.
don't sweat it.
We got that.
It doesn't rain and were abusive.
When we find a resource,
if we could actually tap into the ocean beach from people would be fucking
pissed because the beach would be like a couple hundred yards away and a few
years and a half to the shoreline.
If we'd suck that bitch dry,
it may come to the,
it might.
It really might.
It may very well,
but I don't know.
You know,
man,
I've only,
every time I come to California it's all,
it's always in and out.
Yeah.
Quicker tourist stuff.
We were here,
we did Conan and played at the troubadour a month or two back and we were here
for about four days and that's the most time I've ever spent consecutively in
La.
So I,
but I've never been able to really get the lay of the land is find out what I
knew.
I liked Redondo.
Yeah.
Ever.
Donald's nice.
It's very chill though.
Heme Kinda feel that's what Tommy buns lives.
Tom's girl lives in Redondo.
He fucking loves it.
It's,
it's very chill.
Like any of those beach communities are very chill allies,
gripe.
It's great.
I talk shit about it sometimes,
but it's just the amount of people.
I just don't think people value things that they have in too much abundance.
And I think there's an issue with people when you get over a certain population,
I think we just naturally get a little more callous or you just don't give a
fuck about each other.
Like if you go to like a really small town and you go the store,
people say hi to each other because there's not that many fucking people.
It's only a few thousand people in the town.
I mean,
yeah,
they're going to get some small minded gossipy bullshit too.
But I don't necessarily think that has to be the case in a small town.
But I think the benefit of being in a smaller populations,
people are just like a little less intruded upon by sensory input.
Everybody's a little less on edge.
Yeah.
California is just,
there's 20 million people plus Mexicans in the city.
I say plus Mexicans with respect because
I mean people that have come over here from Mexico,
which I think you should just be able to come over.
I don't,
I don't believe in,
I think it's ridiculous that people who want to work,
they should be forced to stay in this shitty patch of dirt because they just got
a bad roll of the dice.
They were born there.
I think we're just scared.
The good spots like here,
we're scared it's going to balance out somehow and they're going to come over
and fuck it up.
We just gotta figure out a way to not have it,
fuck it up.
Just got to figure out a way to not have crime and poverty and all the different
issues that we've just completely ignored in poor communities.
Not have that effect.
Everybody's like low level of happiness that's living in these big groups,
but to just to imprison someone in a shit country cause they were fucked and
they were born there just seems kind of crazy and inhumane to me.
Just seems weird.
You know?
It's pretty Eurocentric.
But I think,
you know,
the illegals,
first of all,
just you know,
they're here,
they're Americans,
we're all immigrants.
You fucks.
But if you counted them,
I don't think they've ever really counted them.
I don't know how many that is.
So I say 20 million plus Mexicans because that's what it is.
It's like the greater la area,
which is a huge area like goes all the way down and wide.
And you know,
it's,
it's such,
so spread out in sprawl.
Something around 20 million people,
which is just an incredible,
that's just the nuts.
I lived in Tokyo for a while.
Woe is younger.
And who were you doing there?
I was in the military.
I got stationed over there.
Wow.
And it's like,
you know,
an island roughly the size of California with the population in United States,
you know.
So,
but it was weird,
something you said earlier about people being crowded.
I just went back last year and visited some friends of mine to help me with a
video project.
And I noticed that even more so now that I'm older.
But I mean,
even on a crowded subway train where you're just jammed in like sardines or
walking to the street,
they're so aware of a little self aware and then just their surroundings.
You know,
you could be crammed in this train literally nut to butt,
but yet nobody's touching anybody.
You know?
There's just really this awareness,
um,
and in
consideration and mutual respect that I think you don't really encounter in a
lot of big cities here.
It's just this like,
get the fuck out of my way.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I found it incredibly polite.
I've only went,
I went to Tokyo once and I was like,
everybody's so polite here,
friendly.
It's amazing.
You
know,
that place is 20 times the size of New York City you could pass out and the
darkest alley with a hundred dollar bills sticking out of each year.
And nobody's gonna fuck with you.
But there's a bunch of African dudes that are moving in.
They're from Africa,
like straight from Africa.
They still hustler guys as well as the [inaudible].
Some of the nightlife districts.
Yeah,
she was,
yeah.
He walked down the street and they try to drag you into some massage joint and
there's like a,
there's just a look about them.
Like,
oh,
sinister shit man.
A wolf guarding the chicken coop.
Well it does have,
there is a very dark underbelly to,
to Tokyo for sure.
That you,
it's hard for guys like you and me to really go fun that
well,
I've had a ensign anyway on the podcast several times.
He's an MMA fighter who was originally from Hawaii but lives in Japan now.
And uh,
he's Japanese and he's friends with all these,
I mean he fought for pride,
which was the biggest MMA organization in the world at one point.
They were in Japan,
uh,
Kaytoo no,
no,
that's,
that's the k one k we get of like kickboxing.
That's a big event to,
they had some MMA events as well,
but pride had these enormous shows where they would do like 90,000 seat arenas.
I mean,
it was just gigantic and ensign was one of their big stars over there.
And he's down with the Yakuza.
So we had all these crazy yakuza stories.
Like
I've hung out with a couple,
a couple
of acoustic guys once they were,
uh,
one was a bookie and the other one I guess he was just like,
you know,
you're,
you sitting in bars and you'd be drunk,
you know,
and they all,
they all it wants this,
especially their learning,
you're American or if you speak English when they all will talk to you and just
figured out what you're about.
And he's got,
you know,
they were drawing,
we just ended up kicking it for a couple of hours,
then I kind of put it together and realize what they did.
Wow.
And uh,
they,
they asked me and a friend of mine that was with me if we wanted to go to
another club and this guy had like this bad ass baby blue 67 corvette.
Um,
really they were just,
they were just young guys like flashing out,
you know,
they just wanted to impress us.
Wow.
You,
and it was weird cause I could tell you to really give a fuck about being
friends with us.
They just wanted to like show us what they were all about and they were young,
probably really lower level guys
and there's a lot of that,
but it's,
it's very,
they're in one specific part of the city,
mostly Shinjuku role,
the Pachinko parlors in organized gambling takes place and the red light.
Um,
and they,
they make it very obvious who they are,
you know what I mean?
And it's an accepted part of the culture more and more so they become less
corrupt.
The government just kind of realized we can try to fight this where we can work
with them and they do a lot of things for the communities that they're in.
Strangely enough,
you know,
to kind of keep order.
But then at the same time you hear stories about some guy might owe a little too
much money and they just literally go and beat him the fuck to death and a train
station with baseball bats or whatever in front of people and they don't do shit
about it.
Whoa.
Was got to get it as a club owner and her punky,
they got murdered a couple of years ago and I don't think anything came of that.
It's just like,
it's just,
that's what happens.
That's what happens.
Whoa.
They have MMA fights between,
uh,
gang members.
They have like Yakuza MMA fights.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
That's a crazy warrior society.
They're so kind.
Those they adhere to Butoh.
I mean,
they,
that's their whole trip is,
is maintaining Samurai culture and they,
that they despise all the westernization that happened post World War II and
yeah,
it's all about codes and honor and you know,
Butoh way in UAE,
his nickname is Yamato democracy,
which is warrior spirit.
The,
this Samurai spirit that everything has to be done with Yamato.
Dimasi when he would go into a fight,
he would write notes to all his friends and his family because he thought he
would die.
Yeah,
right,
right.
A goodbye note,
big Horah and shit.
You just ready to go to war.
I mean,
you know,
that guy was in his fights were so fucking exciting because of that because like
he literally never worried about his own safety.
He would just go in there and just try to test himself and just swing
you ever,
did you ever,
you ever read any of,
uh,
Maria,
you should bow or the other guy that founded I ketone?
No,
no,
since it,
yeah,
he was more of a philosopher really than,
um,
than a martial artist.
He was absolutely a martial artist,
but a lot of his writings always found more interesting.
So,
uh,
you know,
more so than the actual
art.
Well that was really a strange part of Samurai culture.
I'm not nuts,
I shouldn't say strange,
but unexpected.
When I started investigating it or reading about it rather was that they were
required to be balanced and it was encouraged to be a very balanced person.
Balanced,
like in your discipline,
balanced in your artistic expression,
balanced in your understanding of emotions and fears.
It was a very different than when we think of as like a warrior and we think of
like stone cold murder,
Conan the barbarian motherfucker just
I think it was just at its essence,
pure absolute Buddhism.
Like they just live completely in that moment all the time.
Whatever they do,
they are,
they're so intensely focused on,
you know,
in anything,
whether it's trimming a flower or you know,
there's this very certain
element to that culture that I've never seen anywhere else in the world.
Yeah.
I wonder how that happens.
I'd like to talk to someone who's an expert in Japanese culture to explain how
one society does fit into this very unusual pattern.
[inaudible]
one,
how much of it had to do with sword fighting?
Well you know,
that's what you should we talk about,
you know,
cause there's,
there's no,
you can't second guess on a fucking sword fight.
Like in every,
most of you know these Samurai movies.
That's all bullshit.
Cause a lot of these things were one stroke.
You know,
you had to choose that first stroke and then cut them in half.
So there's a lot.
And then with,
with any kind of society like that,
Edo or kindle or whatever,
there's a lot of mutual respect I would imagine.
You know,
because I mean back in the day,
if,
if like a peasant or somebody going to the fucking market taking their fruit to
sell,
if they pass the Sam or on the street and they didn't bow according lear just
basically say good morning,
it got their fucking head off man.
Like right there.
Like no questions.
So you know,
imagine if like walking down the street on Santa Monica was like that today mean
people's behavior would be very different towards one another.
Yeah,
it's,
I don't think it's good not saying that,
but I do think I know what you're saying.
I do think that when people are scared of other people in that way or when they
respect that the other person has that ability to do that to them,
they're carrying a fucking sword like that.
Well,
armed society is a polite society argument.
I tell them necessarily think that's the way to go.
But I do think there is an element of people that need to know that they get
punched in their fucking face.
Like there's a bunch of people that say rude shit to people and they say it only
because they think they can because they're protected by society.
And because of that,
they're oftentimes less respectful than someone who would be like a physically
dominant person in the conversation.
Like I've seen martial artists have conversations with people where you know
they're way,
way,
way more kind or way more considerate in the way they've voiced their concerns
or opinions about something versus people that have never been in a fight in
their life that will get people's face and scream and yell and you motherfucker.
And it's like you're only doing that because this guy's not going to punch you.
Right.
You know you're having this conversation because you're out in public and you
know,
this guy's not just going to pick you up and drop you on your head.
But if he wanted to,
he could.
Like,
he shouldn't talk to people like
that was there aren't any repercussions for being an asshole.
Exactly.
It's only the repercussions are only verbal,
you know,
and they feel like if they keep it on that ground,
like they can bully the bully,
even they could go after them if they keep it completely verbal,
if they know the guy's not going to do anything,
you big fucking stupid piece of shit.
You know,
they can say it and they know he's not going to smash your head like a Zit.
As long as you're protected by society,
you can get away with being pretty shitty to some people.
So I don't think it's good to chop people in half with swords,
but I do think it might have something to do with the reason why they're
considerate.
What,
you know,
it's weird how cultures develop in these unusual ways when they're just
separated.
Like the,
the Japan is an island and they're separated from other people.
So they,
they've developed it there.
I mean,
there's very similarities to other,
each eastern cultures and their approach to things,
but they're different,
you know,
they have their own thing going on
every,
I think every place has its own thing going on.
I was in DC,
I guess back in April.
And,
uh,
I was trying to catch the train to go to show,
I can remember as New York or Boston and I was at the Amtrak station in DC.
And then southern happened where there was a down power line,
like way up north that had taken out a lot of routes and they,
they basically cancelled or delayed all,
all the trains going out of the station.
And when they put the announcement up,
it just,
the place fucking erupted.
I mean,
I've never witnessed
such a self important display of human behavior in all my life as in Washington
DC that they,
the Amtrak station.
They're like,
there's this line of suited briefcased,
you know,
guy,
they all just got right in the,
in the,
uh,
Amtrak employees faces one at a time.
Like trying to explain to them how much more important their life was and
everyone else's who had just been inconvenienced,
you know,
sitting in this place.
And I mean,
it was like I had to retreat into myself.
It was just so surrounded by it.
And,
uh,
I was just,
I saw a pregnant lady get fucking bumped out of the way.
Some dude.
I mean,
he's a disgusting man and wow.
I don't know,
you would never see that in Japan.
People would just deal,
I don't know if you'd ever see that in England,
you know?
I mean,
who's to say is that,
that's just the Uber successful hyperfocus shithead thing that we have that
other countries just don't have.
Like they have the discipline but they don't have this marauding focus thing
that a lot of like American businessmen sort of embody this ids Gogi you know,
it's Wall Street fucking Gordon Gekko greed is good.
And now that kind of Shit I was,
I would say,
you know,
Wall Street in DC,
places like this tend to cultivate a bit more intense version of that.
I was just there Saturday night.
I had a great fucking time.
Yeah,
it's a great party town.
But uh,
yeah,
I don't know why.
I don't know what happened.
I just couldn't believe what I was seeing.
It seems like it affected her in place.
Really did.
It's a weird place.
I mean that's the death star.
It's right there.
I mean,
all the world's wars are all like kind of,
sort of are organized and it's weird geometrical building there,
you know,
so this is a thing.
It's there that there's the penthouse,
which is just outside of there.
And then there's the White House,
which is this weird fucking building in a park where the commander in chief of
the number one conquering army the world has ever known.
That's where he sleeps and everybody passes by the castle and some sort of
strange formation,
a big circle.
You drive around,
everybody points at it.
It's a weird place to be.
You're just,
you're red like the,
the history of the layout of the city and why it was later.
What is the,
do you remember it?
It's got all sorts of weird does not masonic is it?
Yes.
Yeah.
Some weird masonic implications and it's all very specific.
And it's geometry.
This may not be true.
I think I read somewhere that they part of it,
like why the streets are all one way and why it's so fucking confusing to drive
around in DC is that um,
in case it was ever invaded,
they wanted to make it difficult for whoever was coming to get from the shore
into the capitol.
That makes sense.
That totally makes sense.
Why do you mean,
why would you like to have it?
Like,
so you could do an easy driveway.
You just get on the highway and go really fast.
She want to make it right with super complicated.
Like I'm like,
what does that street Lombard Street in San Francisco,
that's what they should do.
Have that shit set up.
It's a cool city too.
You know it well,
it's,
it's got a lot of weird history to it.
It's like if you stop thinking about it,
yeah,
there's a website on the sacred geometry and assembles of Washington d say,
oh,
and he sort of explains sacred geometry,
the whole thing,
like what it mimics and the different,
all the different dimensions.
So freaky stuff,
man.
It's freaky because you know that these guys,
they really were like into ancient cultures.
They really were into these weird groups that they would form.
I mean,
there's that skull and bones shit that's not fake.
That's real.
It's fucking weird.
They,
when they really are a part of all this stuff.
Were they in the pine cones?
I don't know if they were in the pine cones and,
no,
that's,
that was a big thing in a lot of ancient Catholic art.
Right now there's a giant pine cones outside of the Vatican.
Yeah.
The pine cone supposedly represents the pineal gland,
which is the seat of the soul in ancient Egypt and which is where now they've
actually proven that DMT has made,
it's pretty speculative until real recently,
at least in rodents,
right?
Yes.
It's a mammals.
Yeah.
Rick Strassman.
Um,
and that group that he's involved with,
the cottonwood research foundation,
they put it together and just getting it in a live road and being able to prove
that this third eye in the middle of your head actually is producing the
psychedelic chemicals pretty fucking crazy.
The people that knew that they designed the White House sign all that shit.
Oh yeah.
Sort of.
Probably they're probably copy.
And people who knew it probably didn't even know why they had buckets of that
shit.
Do you think they had DMT back when they were building?
Like the,
the White House?
It was here,
but was it,
do you know,
they didn't even find out about I only first synthesized.
That's a good question.
Um,
I think IOWASCA was discovered by Western civilization,
the 1850s and I think it was a,
I think they figured out what was in it when they were isolating the alkaloids
in it.
And they,
they originally wanted to call it telepathy,
the alkaloid they isolated,
but then they found out that it was out already isolated as a,
the compound harming.
And that sin,
um,
that's in the plant that is connected to Iowasca has the Mao inhibitor.
Right.
So this is like,
this is all like the early 1,980,
late 818 hundreds,
early 19.
They figured that shit.
How do they know what plans to boil together in order to the activity and how
they know the thousands?
Yeah.
How'd they figure it out?
It's not an easy process.
I mean,
how many species of plants can there be in the Amazon?
You know what I mean?
How they found the right to,
well,
what's fucked up is that all,
there's hundreds of thousands of different plants.
They found,
uh,
not just the right to,
but they were,
they found out how to do it in this weird way where you have to mash up the
vines and you add in the leaves and you boil it down and it's,
it's a very involved process that takes hours to make true Iowasca but nobody
knows how they did it.
They say that the plants told them how to do it,
which is just as good an explanation as anything except that if you're high on
mushrooms,
plants will tell you some shit.
I've had conversations with
traffic signals,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Imagine if everything really was alive,
we just couldn't tune into it.
You know?
I mean,
if you're,
your table really was alive and you tables really had consciousness,
it's just uh,
just sits there.
It's consciousness is very different than ours.
It's not,
it's not important for it to move.
It just is where it is.
If you chop it up,
it doesn't freak it out,
but it has some sort of a feel to it.
That's interesting.
I mean obviously it's not provable.
No,
but that Rupert Sheldrake guy who was on before
Rupert,
who was on a couple of weeks ago,
he thinks that everything has a memory.
He thinks that objects contain a memory and that that's why like people don't
want to live in a house where someone's been killed.
Like you walk in,
you have a weird feeling of really say one of the,
one of the more common side effects of hide those silicide.
When was inanimate objects tend to develop personalities or you kind of perceive
them as much more characterized and normally
it's all condensed matter.
Who fucking knows,
right?
Yeah.
Well who does,
that's,
that's another part of the whole what is,
what is a thing?
What is an object that really fucks with your head when you start thinking about
the fact that most Adams,
like it's all,
it's mostly space.
Like is all this is starred space is all the stuff in there where it's
undefined.
Like there's a lot,
a lot of,
lot of nothing and it's all just
sorta somehow or another cohesive and becomes a table energy condensed to a very
slow vibration.
Right?
Yeah.
That's the Hicks line.
Here's Tom with the weather.
All of it sounds bizarre.
The,
the,
just the idea that Adams,
we're trying to figure out what subatomic particles are and that there's these
particles inside Adams.
Like we don't know what the fuck is going on with all those things.
Like what our roles have you followed this hydrogen collider thing?
Which one?
The Higgs Boson.
Yes.
It's just fat.
I mean,
I don't know that that's the kind of stuff I was tripping out on when the record
got written.
I mean it's just like,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't pretend to understand it.
I'm definitely a hobbyist,
but I'm fascinated by like string theory and yeah.
In the concept of independent,
freestanding dimensional realms of energy that all kind of hold one another
together.
Oh,
I'm fascinated that someone's mind is so not just so tuned in to how the nature
of the universe works,
but so tuned in that they've taken theoretical
particle a made the subject of this gigantic science project that involves
hundreds of different fucking countries.
Like I think it's like a hundred different countries.
I over 10,000 different scientists,
something like that.
The photo gallery of of the actual facility.
It's the same,
the most insane things I've ever seen like some the amount of time and years it
took them to build this thing.
It's just,
it's incredible.
I don't even want to know what the price tag look like.
It's billions,
billions of dollars and it's all to collide particles so that they can produce
this Higgs boson potter.
That's amazing origin.
Well they also found that cork glue glue on plasma,
I think it is,
which is like supposedly the heaviest matter that they've ever discovered and we
will pull that up.
It's some insane amount of weight.
These things have that.
That's something that was figured out.
Yeah.
Cork one plasma weight.
It's just insanely dense.
The densest matter created ever.
Um,
that they,
they figured this out.
That is actually a real thing when they,
uh,
we're doing some of the experiments,
the exotic material is more than a hundred thousand times hotter than the inside
of the sun and is denser than a neutron star.
Wrap your fucking head around that.
It acts like a perfect liquid.
Can we see it?
I think they can,
but very brief.
You know,
it's like you're,
you're seeing it almost in a calculation dark.
Yeah.
Or by triggering hundreds.
I mean,
I think it's so heavy that if you had a piece of it,
like,
like that you could look at like a marble,
it would probably sink through the center of the universe.
I mean,
just go right to the fucking right through the,
I don't know.
Aliens fit.
It would probably go to the center of the planet and just hang out there.
Yeah.
Aliens bit burned through the fucking courtroom.
That's insane.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be unbelievably heavy.
Like more like,
I could give you the numbers if I could find it,
but I think it's one of those things where you can't even,
you can't even imagine,
it doesn't make any sense.
And that's something that they figured out is actually a real,
I mean,
if there's,
they're looking for the point of origin,
right?
Like they're looking for the God particle or wear whatever caused the big bang.
Or,
you know,
there's a,
there's this j swit priest appeared tailored day short.
Danny wrote a lot of really weird,
controversial things.
But,
um,
I think he actually got blackballed by the Vatican and early 20th century.
But,
uh,
you read this book,
the phenomenon of Man,
we talks about the Omega point,
the origin,
the first point of all complex consciousness or the,
the,
the source of the universe that like emanated everything that we know and that
ever has been into existence.
And he,
he was basically trying to establish a symbiotic relationship between science
and religion and evolution in spirituality,
which is,
it wasn't a very popular opinion in the,
in the Vatican,
in the 1920s.
Um,
he,
he had this theory that it all emanated from this one point or the Omega point
and that eventually consciousness will reach a state of complexity that's so
advanced that it will no longer require a physical vessel or,
or a human body or anything to inhabit itself.
And then it will,
it will keep evolving until it returns back to the highest state of complexity,
which can only be the same place it came from because whatever started it had to
be the source of this true divine whatever.
So once it goes back,
you know,
but basically,
the reality is we perceive it and this is a coordinate with a lot of modern
quantum physics.
It's just this manifestation that we sort of project out to convince ourself
that we're not actually consciousness experiencing itself.
If that makes sense.
Like there's,
you know,
we're not little special flowers and individuals.
We're all literally the same
people are pulling the car over to the side of the road right now,
jumping out and run into the woods.
Yeah.
Then know,
usually just scared the shit out of people.
It's all going well.
It.
If the universe is 14 point whatever billion years old,
like they say,
I didn't,
I it's not,
not my idea.
No,
it's a great idea of what I'm saying is what,
why wouldn't it be,
you know,
who knows what?
They might be fucking 100 billion times older than that,
like might know,
not have any age.
It might just be a constant cycle of that happening down too compressed tiny
spots,
smaller than the head of a pen,
the entire universe.
And then boom,
big bang over and over and over again.
It might just happen.
It might just compress.
I mean,
just over the course of who knows how many billions of years and just
continually do that.
If it happened once,
like why,
why would we think that it's only like it's a onetime sale.
Well this,
fuck it.
You know,
they don't sell,
sell the Big Bang is headed your way.
Big Bang.
I mean it's just pockets of infinity stacked upon each other.
You know,
listen to this shit I found,
I found out what the way this stuff is.
This is going to fuck your head up.
One cubic centimeter of this cork glue on plasma weighs 40 billion tons.
What?
It's pretty dense.
What the fuck?
How much is that?
What is 40 billion tons?
Just fuck.
I don't both times a ton is 2000 pounds,
right?
What is that?
What?
The skyscraper
for way 40 billion tons.
I mean,
what does it,
what the fuck was 40 billion times?
I don't know.
I don't even think.
Do you think a skyscraper waste 40 billion tons?
That's insane.
And that's a cubic centimeter.
So if you like through that at somebody,
they're not catching it would be wrecking house.
I just go right through your hand.
Boom.
Right through the center of the earth.
A fucking,
they'll figure it out.
One centimeter weaponize it as they found it and a centimeter is tiny.
We don't use those little bitchy ass little units of measurement and my America,
but that's a little tiny fucking thing.
It's about that big,
right?
It's tiny cubic centimeter,
40 billion tons.
If there was a big bang,
why wouldn't we think that there could be an infinite number of big bangs,
an infinite number of expansions and contractions and maybe what we are
currently and we like to think of as the highest state of life available.
What we are is just,
this is what exists when you have this state of the universe and there's a type
of consciousness that exist when the universe becomes no longer physical and
that might be what you're experiencing when you smoked DMT.
You might be experiencing these other forms of reality that are there.
You just don't tune into them while you're in this state that you can access
them through these chemical doorways while you're sleeping,
while you're meditating,
when you,
you reach these different tunes of mind that people have been exercising and
having a disciplined practices to try to reach these frequencies.
They've been doing it forever.
They're not doing it because there were,
well,
I know I'm starving to death,
but I want to try to figure out a way to reach some shit that's not even real.
Yeah,
they were.
They were doing it because they haven't had success in it in some way or
another.
Just changing the channel really.
Possibly,
you know,
possibly.
I've never,
I've never a weird,
my experience is very limited with,
I've only encountered it twice and I've,
I've never had,
I guess what you call a breakthrough.
What have you had when you've done it?
Uh,
it was like,
well,
the first time I don't,
I,
I didn't know what I was doing and it,
the bubbling,
it was just weird.
Everything was just some weird associations that kind of freaked me out and I'm
like,
there's no way that's going to be healthy.
But then the second time I got like this extreme,
I don't know how to describe it other than say it was an intense downward shift
in gravity.
What it felt like gravity really,
you know,
that crest at the top of the first hill on roller coaster from everything just
kind of,
I felt like something was,
he like pushing me down.
Um,
and then I,
you know,
I'd read so much in research so much,
uh,
most of my understanding came from reading and then how that tied together with
other experiences that I've had or how that related to things that I've always
been fascinated with or,
or subscribe to maybe on a personal notion,
but,
uh,
it,
it felt like something putting you almost in a,
we're going to trance,
you know,
but I was still very much aware.
I was,
I,
you know,
I don't think I got a very strong dope.
We will you taking regular DMT or five Meo DMT.
The NN NN yeah.
And you,
so he didn't have any visual.
Oh,
I did know I had some visuals,
but it was,
I wouldn't say that it was a,
it was probably as intense as the strongest silicide van trip I've ever had,
but I was still very much,
I never lost cognitive thought.
I was aware of my body could open my eyes.
I was still,
I knew I was in the room.
I saw,
um,
almost like these Easter island head sort of things sort of just kind of coming
out of the way with chasers and,
and it felt like something one and I just was like the cusp of something and it
just,
it was kind of over and there was,
the room definitely looked,
there was a weird energy,
like everything had this crystalline sort of melty effect.
But I mean it wasn't overwhelmed.
We certainly not anything like what uh,
what they've described,
some of the research volunteers talks about the volunteers are doing it slightly
differently because they were feeding the intravenous,
supposed to be a Moodle.
Actually that's how I got to visit with dockers Strassman about five days ago.
Um,
you answered a lot of questions and went more into detail,
but yeah,
they were like massive doses man.
And for like four to road before 80 to 120 milligram doses all in one morning
back to back.
And um,
they're hitting hard just,
yeah,
there's no resisting it at that point.
Yeah.
My,
my knowledge is from a purely amateur academia.
So,
and incorporating that into certain other things was like know how it may or may
not resemble elements of Tibetan Buddhism and what people describe like these,
like the Bardos and independent realms of energy and where your soul was faced
with these entities that test you in ways and how you react to those,
determine how you might trans migrate or reincarnate into another life.
And I didn't even know about it until a year ago.
Man,
it was sitting on,
I was visiting a buddy of mine that was in town and uh,
and it was just really strange because I've listened to your podcast off and on
for a while and he used to listen a lot of Terrence lectures and for whatever
reason,
it just never,
I never heard about it or maybe it passed in front of me when I was younger and
I didn't know what it was and just said no cause related.
It's like a PCP or something that shit away.
And uh,
but yeah,
I'll send a friend of mine's house and it's his father.
I can't remember if his father had already passed or if he was just,
he had gotten very ill with terminal cancer.
And,
um,
he was pretty distraught about and we're just hanging out and he's kind of
telling me everything he'd been dealing with and I,
you know,
I didn't know what to really say or two to comfort him,
cause he's obviously,
you know,
you find out your dad's dying fucks you up.
And I,
you know,
I just was like,
well,
you know,
man,
some people think that there's no such thing as death and you know,
you lived to die when we die so we can really live.
And uh,
you know,
like the Buddhist think that there's this other realm you go to,
it's just the most pure bliss and like this ocean of love and you,
and you feel that joy and euphoria and either go on to nirvana or you go back
into another life depending on how you live this one.
And he's like,
man,
that sounds a lot like DMT.
And I was like,
what the fuck is DMT?
And,
uh,
he's like,
really man,
you just come off,
there was a,
you've all people you,
and I was like,
I'd never,
it didn't have a clue.
And he paid,
he played an expert.
We're right there on the porch from one of your podcasts where you kind of going
on this rant about it.
And I'm like,
all right,
I need to dig in here cause I'm seeing a lot of similarities and symbiotic
touchstones.
And I went home,
man,
and probably spent the next three months just reading everything I could find
and like scouring forums and,
and,
and then going back and reading metaphysical publications and a lot of theology
and bouncing the shit around.
And then I found out my wife was going to have a child and it just was like my
last great existential listic dilemma,
you know what I mean?
So I was,
I want to write a record about all this shit,
uh,
record it.
Like it was an outer space.
And then Dave and I just kinda wanted to tackle it from the standpoint in terms
of the mix of,
I wanted it to sound like a lot of my favorite records did that I used to listen
to when I was hired on my fucking mind on mushrooms or Dextromethorphan or
anything else.
You know,
and you can do all that with tape.
I think like we were talking about vinyl early settled.
So when you put the headphones on,
you want it to kind of just figure eight around your head,
you know?
And you could do that with tape better than you can digitally.
It's a lot of people will say no,
but I think at the end result is a much better,
um,
texture for lack of a better term.
You know what I mean?
Um,
I dunno.
It's hard to,
it's hard to explain,
but the digital manipulation with computers that you,
what you can do with music now,
it's pretty incredible,
but it's easy.
It's so easy to overdo it.
You lose that human [inaudible] sound of the instruments you want everything.
I think to a certain degree has to be understated.
Isn't there,
like there's something really cool about hearing the pic moving across the
guitar when you know that that's what you're hearing.
Yeah.
It,
it gives you this certain strange connection and then stead if that was like
cleaned up,
this perfect sound is perfect.
Synthesize how many,
this is still a cool thing,
but it's missing out on whatever,
whatever makes it,
whatever that unique feeling that you get from someone's artists.
You know,
when you see someone,
like David Cho was here the other day and he had some paintings and just seeing
his paintings and knowing him,
he's amazing.
Yeah.
And it's like you're getting his unique art.
It's very uniquely his.
And yet that's what's missing with all this protools shit.
Right.
Well you get perspective.
Yeah.
I mean with any real art,
I think you just kind of,
it's somebody you know,
that's what you do.
You observe and you assimilate and then you put out your perception of this
thing and hopefully a way that everybody can relate to,
you know,
you're kind of putting the unspeakable
and into a visual,
you know what I mean?
If that makes sense.
SORTA.
And what do you,
what do you think about people that make like electronic music like that?
You know what man,
I love a lot of that shit.
I think,
I think anything,
any good music is soul music and you can put soul in anything.
Like somebody really put a lot of time into sequencing all that shit out and
there's a lot of crap.
Just anything else,
you know,
just like anything else.
But I dare anybody to go stand in front of a Scrillex concert and telling me
that that's not bad.
The fuck ass.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
exactly.
I can,
I can listen and appreciate anything as long as it's done from a,
and you can tell when it's not.
I mean,
it's like anything else about today we were,
we were talking earlier about how if you had a record deal in the 1970s you had
to be a bad motherfucker,
had to be happy.
But isn't it better that it's more accessible today?
Well,
you'll get more quantity and you'll get a lot of shitheads.
But you were also,
the quality will slip through too,
do you think?
No,
I don't,
I don't think it's a good thing at all because we know people have to sift
through a lot of mediocre bullshit to fund the real stuff.
But they found you.
So if someone finds you,
you could get spread pretty quick now.
Yeah.
But it,
it became at some point it became this thing where,
you know,
everybody wants to,
wants to be in a band at some point,
whether it's,
um,
excuse me,
a lot of people now,
hey,
coffee man,
bulletproof.
Uh,
it feels to me like there's a,
there's an element of it where a lot of people think that playing music for a
living is a right.
It's just something you can decide to go,
do.
You know what I mean?
Like,
Oh,
I'm going to put a Kickstarter campaign up because we need a new van to tour in,
so give me some money so I can go to her and played music.
Fuck you man.
You know,
get out there and earn it.
Because even though,
I mean I got a wife that I love and a four month old son that I've seen exactly
like 12 days of his life and I spent all the time in a van with three or four
stinky other dudes going out and playing to a bunch of drunk strangers.
And it's still the greatest fucking job on planet,
you know?
And if it never went anywhere beyond where it is right now for me,
I feel like I've just basically clawed my way to the beginning as it were.
Um,
and if we're playing clubs to three or 500 people,
I mean,
I can,
I can make a living at some point doing that.
And it's,
I'm not compromising in any way.
I don't have to wake up and like report to anybody.
I'm not sitting in fucking meetings for a week about what my haircut should look
like.
And I just feel like there's a lot of people like you see and you used to see
back in club dates and you just,
you can tell like the blatant blinding narcissism that permeates this industry
were people literally almost come to fucking fist fights over who's going to
play what sets spot at this rinky dink club that nobody gives a shit about it
just because they think there's going to be somebody there and it's going to
recognize my genius and this is going to change everything and I think could get
a lot of entitlement because of that.
Um,
and that's to me probably the worst aspect of,
of working in the music business is entitled
musicians.
Yeah.
Well everybody comes at it from a different place and everybody,
I'm,
I'm talking about sort of all aspects of show business and everybody handles
their own needs in a different way.
Like some people go in less needy,
some people are just completely obsessed with the idea of success and it's just
like permeates every cell of their body and goal as opposed to the actual art.
Yeah,
yeah.
You can hear that Shit really pretty easy.
But what it,
that's why people go crazy when that shit slips through though.
Right.
And that stuff works well.
It's always worked.
I mean it's not a new concept.
They're pop music's been around since the very first days of the music business
has what it was all about.
But there's good pop music too,
right?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
That's what's weird about it.
Right?
It's all just good.
Song's a good song.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's a,
you can go crazy thinking about it.
So I try not to.
So is it necessary that you live in Nashville?
No,
it's not at all.
I thought it would be when in the beginning it was because you have to be
playing in those clubs,
which are some of the most thankless clubs in the entire nation.
Like you can't make money playing in Nashville.
It's just Kinda,
it's where you go to find people that can help you really.
Um,
and I've been very fortunate in that regard that we're,
I,
I was found sort of by the,
maybe the handful of actually trustworthy folks in town.
Um,
my,
me and my manager never took a dollar from me for the first three years.
He was just kind of like a friend that gave me solid advice and told me what not
to do because he's watched guys like me get chewed up and spit out for 20 years.
He was almost retired basically.
And uh,
he just said,
I'll help you and if it turns into a Gig,
I want the Gig.
And he was like,
yeah,
all right man,
you got to deal.
And
just kind of like put this wall up between a lot of that shit that tap that
happens to a lot of people and they get taken advantage of and you end up bitter
as a result and your creativity suffers.
Right.
Um,
so I just decided,
well,
if I just don't have anything to do with any of that,
then that can never happen.
So now,
four years later,
you know,
I have a great book agent,
I have a manager and,
and these people that kind of help facilitate us getting out and playing shows
on the road.
And I mean,
I could start a tour from anywhere.
So my wife and I talked about that and it was like,
why do we even still live here?
Because we don't go out,
you know?
Yeah.
It's like a,
the Hollywood thing too,
right?
There's a lot of people that are comics and we're on the road all the time and
they still live here.
But you can practice here.
Do you need a place to practice or can you,
you can practice in a studio,
right?
What do you mean?
Like rehearsals?
We never rehearse.
He never rehearse.
Yeah.
I got a very small compact ban.
We,
we've been doing this and they're beginning.
We rehearsed every day for like six months to get the chemistry they were.
Now the shows are basically every show's different.
It's very dynamic.
And um,
would you like to keep it lean because of that?
He can get the freedom.
You can kinda just go here,
there and everything's just sort of an extension of my acoustic guitar.
So you kind of just,
we never write set lists.
Really.
Yeah.
Just kind of feel the audience fill room and try to just maintain focus on
dynamics.
So when you new songs,
um,
do you write them together?
Do you write them yourself and then bring it to them and yeah,
myself typically I don't like to play songs.
I haven't recorded in the studio,
formulate it and then get it down and committed and then they,
they kinda tend to come to life all on their own.
Over the course of a year and a half year.
You ended up at the end of the tour.
That song sounds nothing like the one you put down on the tape.
Why is that?
You just,
you get boards,
you've pushed things and go different places and try,
you know,
try to just keep it exciting and take risks and it makes you a better musician,
obviously eight months later from the time you recorded that song,
if you've been playing every night for two hours,
if you haven't become a better musician by that time,
then you're doing this for the wrong reasons.
So now when you go into make your next record,
ideally you know you've trained harder,
right?
Right.
So you will change like the rhythm will you,
will you,
will you add lines to songs?
Only when I forget the other ones.
Um,
does that happen all the time?
All the time,
but nobody can really understand what the hell I'm saying anyways.
Fake my way slower through it and they don't,
they're none the wiser.
Um,
would you ever consider doing like a residency somewhere?
Like a Vegas type thing where people always came to you though we may think that
you always have to tour.
That's the kind of thing you do when your career's over.
And is that what it is?
Just getting started,
but I always wondered like,
Bam,
the trap,
we were talking when you got here,
you were beat because of traveling.
And I'm beat because of travel and I was just trying,
I was only traveling for two days and now just the flying back and forth from
Philly to DC,
la to Philly,
DC to la and do that in two days and just like,
ugh.
If you could just stay put,
if they could all come to you.
Okay.
Um,
you know what I mean?
Or it's part of the Gig,
like the travel and the stuff that sucks and being away from your family,
that's what,
that's where you,
you know,
musicians play music and that's where you become a musician,
rule 10 thousands and all that.
But it's so truthfully for me,
man,
it's really bittersweet.
Everything that's happening right now because I've been,
like I said,
for off and on for a lot of different reasons that I've put it down over the
years.
What,
I've been doing this a long time and I've had a very thankless capacities.
It's all just been very passionate and driven.
And then now,
you know,
I've got a newborn son and uh,
everything's happening and I'm just,
I'm just slammed so much that I'm exhausted a lot of times.
And uh,
it's really weird because I'm out here and all this stuff we've worked so hard
for is finally happen.
But a lot of these,
I just really want to be at home.
That's the catch 22.
That's what I get for,
for starting at 34 that's where you get
for being successful too.
Now you're busy.
If you weren't,
you'd wish you were busy,
which shows on yeah,
be sit on the couch wishing I had a gig.
Yeah.
It's damned if you do.
You're way better off with this damned.
Yes.
The damned if you do is way better than damned if you don't.
I just,
I just miss my family a lot.
I of course,
can you take them on the road with you?
Ideally that's the goal.
Right?
But you know that certain other thing I got to take care of,
the band I got to take has a lot of,
there's a lot of,
you don't really make money touring.
It's just how you build awareness.
Wow.
What a pain in the ass.
So if you don't make money touring,
how do you make money?
That's a good question.
Joe Rogan
because album sales are real issue now.
It's so funny cause people that you know back home or that I haven't talked to
since I was in high school and you know,
all of a sudden you start getting texts from unknown numbers and shit and people
you haven't talked to and they're like,
man you fucking made it man.
It's like large blowing it up.
It's like they think because you get some press
and in 10 or 12 media outlets that you're just raking in the dough and that's
just not the reality.
Making records is fucking expensive.
Packaging records is expensive.
Like especially when I wanted to put out vinyl
barely pays for itself.
Yeah.
We never got into how much the first one cost we sorta started never uh,
the first one because that,
because of some of the guys we used on the session,
they're doing like a pig,
the pig and the guy named Robbie Turner,
he's placed deal for Waylon and other guy really serious to steal for Waylon.
And so they,
they I drink whiskey.
Yeah.
Well there was this dream come true scenario where this investor came into the
picture
and what's going to help out.
And,
and Blah,
blah,
blah.
And then at the last minute it all,
you know,
went away
due to negotiations.
So then I got stuck with the bill on this record that I thought I was going to
have help making and it was all about all of a sudden done about 27 grand that I
didn't have.
Wow.
So spent that year on the road playing and then trying to pay that debt off.
And then about a year later,
once we're coming back off tour,
we're about five grand in the black.
And I just spent all this time on the road with this,
with this young band had put together,
working out all these songs and just decided,
all right,
well let's just go make the,
make a record.
Wow.
It has to be quick because we don't have the cash,
you know.
So I paid the guys in the band 1000 bucks and then the other thousand went
towards paying the engineers and my buddy Dave,
the producer just kind of did it for free on Spec to help out.
Wow.
Um,
that's all.
I think the whole thing cost about 4,500 bucks and uh,
which it was just very,
very inexpensive to make an help and that,
and now this record that sort of started,
I guess what we'll call it,
the beginning of a career,
if I hadn't taken that in and tried to shop it to anybody,
you know,
any,
any major label or music row entity or even a lot of indie labels and laid that
down one,
it's a country record.
Two of talking about rep aliens and fucking turtles and shit man,
you know exactly as well as I do.
How that would have gone.
Yeah.
You know,
what's the turtle thing?
What's,
that's a,
a jocular expression,
I guess from a Stephen Hawking book.
Um,
it's,
it's a,
it's like an old comedic reference to the infinite regress problem in cosmology,
which,
you know,
the,
basically all the shit we were talking about earlier and there's a story,
I guess there was some professor at Oxford or somewhere giving a speech and
explaining how the universe works and,
and,
and everything else.
And some little lady stood up and said,
you know,
that's really clever.
I know you think you're smart but you're wrong.
And he's like,
oh yeah,
well what's,
what's the,
what's the truth?
And she's like,
well,
the earth sits on the back of this chart,
cosmic turtle and carries it through space.
And he said,
well,
what's carrying the turtle?
And she's like,
oh,
that's pretty clever,
but it's another turtle.
And he's like,
well,
what's under that?
She's like,
you might as well,
you're wasting your time.
It's turtles all the way down.
And so Hawkin referenced this in brief history of time,
and it's weird because you can look back,
um,
Hindu cosmology and a lot of,
uh,
some native American tribes,
they'll hold these like earthly turtles in the higher reverence and the
symbology of it all.
And you find that story and different cultures throughout,
you know,
space,
but thousands of years.
But there's this weird,
weird reference to this cosmic turtle and none of the Indians or the Hindu
thought there were these four elephant standing on the back of the turtle and
the earth was a flat disk rescue.
I don't,
it's back.
Whoa.
And it just crew through space.
There's a lot of artwork you can find associated to this.
I just thought that it was really the,
the,
the record at its core is about love,
you know,
being like this one universal truth.
And you get a lot of people look to religion and a lot of people look to drugs.
And I'm not saying you can't get really spiritual experiences from all of those
things,
but I think love at the end of the day is the one thing that really,
I've ever found forced me to want to wake up and really try to be a better human
being every day.
You know?
So that was the main point of the,
of the album and the turtles thing was just kind of,
it's,
it's a way of saying if you get into an argument with somebody and you realize
it's just pointless and you're going back and forth,
it's turtles all the way down because like,
don't nobody really know Shit,
you know?
And we're all just trying to not kill each other.
So,
I don't know.
I decided it would make a good country song.
Well that's a fascinating theory on her part of me.
What did she mean?
Look at that.
There's a picture of the earth with turtles below it.
Who you who did that?
Jamie.
No idea.
Hollingsworth.
Steven.
What a bizarre idea.
There's some really,
really cool visual.
What a bizarre idea.
I'm like,
why?
Why Turtles?
What they're trying to say.
Turtles are the oldest noon
living species on
the planet.
They probably predate crocodiles and the reps hall species.
Um,
and they the 13 symmetrical.
We'll leave the design of the shells.
A lot of like ancient Indian tribes thought that that was in connection with the
13 lunar cycles.
And um,
it's just the ancient creature.
They live a long time.
They're very independent,
self sufficient.
They carry their homes on their back.
So I thought,
I'm really like wise old plus the pineal gland,
you know,
cut that shit open.
There was a little third eye Ballston some of them even have like a translucent
layer.
The top of their skull where the pineal gland sets,
I save turtles for pets.
Really had to get rid of them.
My wife got pregnant,
same Manila.
Well,
they're just dangerous.
They're dirty,
stinky little fuckers,
you know,
there they will give off some fucking series poop disease.
You've got to really stare very messy.
And I would feed them goldfish.
They're not really meant for domestication,
but there's sure.
Cool.
They're the ones I had.
I had Paranas at one point in time,
allegedly,
since they're illegal,
say allegedly,
uh,
and watching Puranas eat is not nearly as cool as watching turtles eat.
Turtles are a motherfucker,
dude.
Really fucking cool.
They grab goldfish and just bite them in half.
Just grab them with their paws.
It's like watching dinosaurs eat and they swim after the goldfish.
They're fucking predatory man.
Like I always thought of turtles as being like the sort of slow moving thing
that really didn't fuck with anybody.
Not nope.
Hungry turtles in a fish tank and some goldfish and you just have an orgy of
slaughter.
I mean,
they're wild to watch that back.
And the only way we're like turtles,
the size of fucking school buses,
you know,
where the,
is that how big they were?
I would find I and everything else was huge.
I mean,
yeah,
I've never had that adequately explained to me why everything was so fucking
big.
And why are the species that lasted diminished through evolution?
Like crocodile,
he'd be like 70 80 foot crocodiles.
It was a different species of crocodile.
But yeah,
the ones that are out now though,
they've been around for hundreds of millions a year.
So that means the ones around now survived the thing that hit the Yucatan,
which is like what?
Okay.
Because sharks did too.
Right?
Sharks had been around in this state for more than a hundred million years.
Yeah.
I don't get it.
It's may amazing that those things are around on.
We get a chance to look at an animal that would have walked freely amongst the
dinosaurs.
When you see a crocodile,
you're essentially seeing a prehistoric beast.
Yeah.
Crazy prehistoric thing.
Covered in armor.
Wattles around,
takes gazelles out and just looking for shit to kill.
Oh,
it's disgusting.
Fucking monsters.
That would make a hell of a pair of shoes though.
Okay.
Yourself?
A couple of Nice croc shoes.
Ooh.
Politan bitches up.
Nice gators.
Alligators or,
uh,
I mean at one point in time they were really extinct or on the verge of
extinction there were really in danger.
That's when I lived in Florida.
We used to feed them and we said throw marshmallows into this place called
Lake Alice.
And they would come up and snatch up the marshmallows and I never would've
thought that they would get so plentiful that they would start hunting them,
but now they turn,
they're trying to kill as many alligators they can.
They just can't keep up with him.
I took him to Lewis Fan boat tours down in New Orleans one time we go out with
like some dude with three teeth,
jumps on the lily pond and starts smacking these alligators in the head and
shit.
And,
but at the end of it,
he had this little baby alligator and a cooler on the boat,
just,
just torturing the shit out of this poor animal,
you know,
and they pass it around.
There's like 14 people in this pontoon out to her in the swamp and everybody
gets a chance to hold this little baby alligator.
So you met,
he's probably scared shitless,
all these weird hormones and so I'm the fucking very last person to get this
thing.
Dude.
I swear to God,
as soon as they,
my wife hands it to me,
it just pissed all over me and him cause you're holding by the tail and just
this fire hydrant of of urine just misting out all over me,
man.
I'm just like,
this was not meant to happen.
It wasn't meant to have me.
The chosen one.
Right.
It was holding in.
It's pay.
It's like I'm going to get the sturgeon
and anoint him with my knowing him and let him know he's the chosen one.
It trusted you because you were probably the only one that wouldn't smash.
It's call open if it pissed all over.
I mean it was nothing to do.
I just kind of had to hold it and let him finish because it's a mouth taped up.
Yeah.
He had like a big rubber band on it.
We had a,
an alligator on fear factor once at a mouth taped up to fuck that man.
Yeah.
This guy,
he jumps out on this little grass pollen and you just see like eight of them in
succession come out of nowhere and starts with mentors and they all jump up.
You know,
he understands the behaviors in the sight line,
but I'm just this guide,
this massive scar on his bald head and literally three teeth in his head.
He's like nab and Devon dumped damp and then I'm like,
I'm going to watch this guy died.
Well had to get this car that man,
I'll get her back though.
I don't know man.
I want to engage as little as possible.
I would have had to ask.
I think.
Yeah,
I would have had to ask that fucks with alligators and he's got an alligator
size bite on his head or he might,
I was afraid he might have been like a veteran.
It almost had like,
it was like a giant scar that went from the back of his neck over his goal.
So I didn't want to.
Right.
Where'd you get the scar man?
How that happened?
I lost all my friends
go on a boat ride.
Yeah.
Oh holy.
Of Shaky memories over it every night in the middle of the night.
I hear the guns,
I hear the explosions.
That's fucked up.
Yeah.
They have watched the show.
Small people,
they make a living just kill an alligator or you're talking about Dev?
Hundreds of alligator tags.
They'll get like a hundred tags and they have to,
they can kill a hundred alligators in a season.
That's when he fucking alligators or are we just sold in the skins?
What do they do?
Yeah,
they saw the skins and the meat to the mean is a delicious,
apparently it's the highest amount of protein.
It's got more protein
per ounce of a,
of alligator meat.
Then I think like any them,
let's try it a couple times.
It's really chewy.
I think it's how you,
how you prepare it.
I would like to try it fresh.
I've only tried it deep fried and like in batter and it was,
you know,
it was forgettable,
but apparently if you get a fresh alligator and someone's a good chef and they
understand how to cook it,
they can.
It's really delicious.
But it's one of those things like a lot of wild game gets real tricky cause
there's no fat.
I think alligator is probably very similar.
Rattlesnake.
Yeah,
I've had Ralph says,
yeah,
it's weird
cause some to I like to just flashed it and some butter.
Yeah.
Oh did you cook it yourself?
No,
my uncle cook the,
Oh wow.
He's one of those pilgrim motherfuckers that just,
that's a chewy,
chewy.
The really distinct flavor.
Yeah.
Wild game tends to be very difficult to cook.
Right.
If you cook it too much,
you fuck it up and then you have to like really be careful.
I bet alligators probably similar in that way.
I'll tell you stood a,
I worked with a guy and that yard pour is a big hunter and he would you bow hunt
and uh,
he moved up to Wyoming so he,
cause he could get like four or six more tags a year.
Then he couldn't use hall and he drive the hour and a half every day.
Even like wow.
Through the winter blizzards to come to this job just so he could,
the kid was just eat up with it,
man,
but he apparently,
he said,
I think the longest distance shot in Wyoming at 23 and then he'd hunt Moose and
elk and everything else will the Boba,
he would cut and he bring in these venison like filet cutlet,
medallions of elk meat,
and we had a grill down at the switch shagging cook that she has a best fucking
thing I've ever tasted in my life because it's hard to go back to eating ground
beef after tasting it,
you know?
Yeah.
Just so good for you,
man.
Yeah.
You just tasted in the meat that it's good for it.
You're like,
whoa.
Apparently Moose is like that too.
I never ate moose before,
but supposed to be unbelievably good.
Like you need it and just go,
my God,
I'm sort of in all of those people that,
that want to get 40 feet from moose with a bone arrow.
That's pretty fucking hardcore,
40 yards,
40 feet is fucking pushing it.
I mean the you,
you,
you better hit it,
right.
I mean,
I'm sure it's happened.
I'm sure someone's been 40 feet,
but you know,
close 40 feet.
I don't have any idea.
Yeah,
40 feet is where the bathroom,
that's the pisser.
Yeah,
you could do it.
I mean,
it could happen,
but Goddamn,
the fact that the Moose hasn't run away or charged you,
or you have to call the men,
you have to pretend that your pussy.
Oh,
saw trying to get some over here.
And then he comes home.
Warmth comes waddling through all 1500 pounds as of like a bull.
Oh,
it's a giant animal.
Or He's seen him in,
in Shit.
Right.
I mean,
like they're there.
I wouldn't say they're mean.
They're defensive and aggressive like a mother and a calf.
You don't ever want to run into that.
I was with a mother and a calf on an island.
We,
uh,
took a boat out to an island and me and Ari and,
this Guy Matt was a guide up in Alaska,
took us salmon fishing valley river jars.
We've pulled up onto this a island and there was a moose Amala Mama Moose there
with her calf.
And we were no more than 30 yards away from her.
It was real touch and go like I was looking at this Moose and she was looking at
us like,
oh for real,
like you motherfuckers are just going to pull up onto this island.
I'm on an island with my baby.
It was one of a big island either,
but his dad owns the island and he has like a resort,
like a camp set up like for fishermen and hunters on this island and so I was
like these cabins and shit there and generators and stuff and the Moose is just
hanging out there just keeping a good eye on us.
But it's a touch,
a big fucking animal.
It's a horse horse size animal and it just thinking about should I stomped this
motherfucker?
They just want to make sure you don't make any weird movements.
Nothing crazy,
nothing predatory.
But we saw several moves while we were there.
They're enormous
big animals.
It's intense man.
There was this island out in Utah.
I was like stay apart antelope pile and it was a buffalo reserve,
but are all these hiking trails and shake?
Could go out there with these buffalo was co would and sometimes could be
roaming freely.
And a friend of mine,
we'd gone out through to hike this peak.
We're coming back down and you can look down,
we could see like five or 600 yards down on the trailers,
these two buffalo just standing.
So you know,
we think,
well fuck,
we'll just keep going.
By the time we get down there,
there'll be gone.
I get to see the herd off in the distance.
And uh,
we come around the bend,
this clear,
this big rock and they're,
they're standing and I didn't know man.
I grew up around a lot of farms and cows and shit and you just walk right
through and get out of the way.
I have no idea.
I don't know anything about Buffalo.
And uh,
my buddy,
he's just like immediately scared shitless.
Britain ran and got up on this rock just kind of not knowing what to do.
And I'm like,
I don't know what I was thinking.
I just kept walking and I get literally 10 feet away from this thing,
standing sideways broad across the trail.
And all of a sudden he just stopped eating grass and turns and looks at me and I
realize his head is the size of a fucking Volkswagen beetle.
And I'm just like,
all right,
this was not very close with you owe like 10,
15 feet.
Oh my God.
And then it dawned on me how incredibly stupid,
oh my God.
And then I'd be like,
this thing probably runs 40 miles an hour.
Like what am I going to do?
And I took,
I didn't know what else to do,
so I took one more step towards,
towards it and it just like kicked up and kind of ran off.
But the fucking ground shook,
you know,
was just like,
oh man.
I mean,
they could have been so bad.
No good songs.
Yeah.
Just stand on the Rock,
you know,
laugh,
have death.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
There's a wild herd of buffalo in Mexico and we're supposed to go hunting there
sometime this winter for that show.
Midi there.
We're going to go buffalo hunting.
We were in Mexico.
I'm actually with the guy,
the producer of the show,
mediator.
Um,
uh,
I dunno,
somewhere in Mexico there's a giant wild of Buffalo.
They brought there in like the 1950s most bison today,
like when you know,
you buy a bison stakes,
most of it's farm raised is very little wild buffalo left in this country,
a lot big percentage of is owned it's property.
People have these big giant game preserves and they,
they have buffalo on them that you can hunt and they have buffalo in these uh,
livestock places where you buy like farmers Buffalo.
That's what buffalo is.
Come down to Ted Turner's or,
yeah,
he's got a bunch of places that sell it,
right?
Isn't it just called teds or something like that?
It's got a big buy buffalo logo.
Apparently.
There's a guy that I'm going to have on the podcast,
um,
that Steve Vernella recommended to me that can tell,
explain in great detail what actually happened to the Buffalo.
But that there's a lot of misconceptions about why the buffalo population was so
high.
And he says there's a direct correlation between smallpox.
Then when the French and the Spaniards,
when they brought over smallpox or whoever brought her,
I guess it was the French,
it wiped out like 90% of the native American population.
And during that time,
the buffalo population just explode,
flourished.
So when we came along and started slaughtering these,
uh,
buffalo in mass,
when I say we white people,
obviously it wasn't you me as long time ago,
but those big piles of buffalo booms of the guilt,
white guilt strong,
they,
the reason why those guys were able to find these animals and such giant numbers
was because the native Americans had experienced this massive loss of casualty.
I mean massive 90% casualty rate because of smallpox,
because they were apparently,
at least in this guy's book,
he's going to come on the podcast soon.
We're working out the dates,
um,
that he,
they were on the verge of a extra,
I guess extra patients,
what they call it in when it's local extinction because the native Americans had
figured out horseback riding.
And once they figured out horseback riding over the course of a couple of
hundred years,
whatever it was,
they had almost completely abandoned agriculture and they were just chasing down
the bison and killing them.
Like fucking crazy.
Evolved hunters.
Yeah.
So the idea was that that they were on the verge of killing off the buffalo even
before those crazy ass came in and did it.
Later on,
a hundred years later,
it's just a smallpox got them and then just,
Oh,
it would have been unheard bloat.
Even if we had to shut up,
they would have continued procreating.
And you've been more Indians,
you know,
probably,
right.
Native Americans.
Yeah.
It is kind of crazy.
We still call them Indians.
One fuck up,
you know,
shiver,
Columbus 600 his dumb ass reciprocated down to me sitting here on your podcast
and I just perpetuated it 500 plus years ago.
He thought he was in India.
Isn't it good enough,
Chris?
Good enough.
Or Chris good enough or made then the fucking Indians.
Look what I did.
Yeah,
they were.
They were some brutal bastards.
Meaning like running around cracking babies' heads on rocks and serial killers
basically.
Well,
the accounts of the missionaries that talked about what Columbus is,
people did their,
they're horrific.
And we never heard that shit when they had Columbus Day.
I Dunno why I celebrate that idiot.
Yeah,
it's very strange phrase trains.
We celebrate that guy.
It seems like there's a bunch of people we missed.
You know,
how come there's no Gandhi day?
We said we celebrate Columbus.
We don't tell Rick Gandhi Day,
you know?
I mean,
I would settle for a Jimmy Carter Day.
Yeah,
right.
Oh,
we're a Christopher Columbus.
Her's a good man.
He does it.
He deserves a day.
Jimmy Carter should have a day.
I agree with you and still to this day is a very good man,
very moral and ethical and just very different than what you perceive to be a
guy who would be the president of United States.
A Hundred Thompson.
He wrote a really great
piece about Carter.
I can't remember which book it was in,
but he just kinda seemed that he was probably like the last real great
politician.
He witnessed some speech somewhere.
I can't remember now.
The details that just,
it's like you felt for the first time,
like he actually heard a politician be a human being and really talking from his
heart.
And I think it led to a pretty heavy impression with him.
But
I keep wondering if that's possible.
Again,
if somewhere in the future,
because of the transparency that we're experiencing now with the social media,
with the Internet,
with the access to information that we have today.
I wonder if like eventually the bullshit artists wall be exposed to the point
where they won't,
they won't be viable anymore.
So a viable business model,
right?
The accountability of the corporations that are financing these politic
politicians,
horrible,
short ours.
I wonder,
I wonder if it's going to come a point in time when we start to see an emergence
of people that are talking in a real sense like collect.
You're talking about real music.
Well,
there's gotta be real politicians too that aren't hacks.
You know,
there's a bunch of shitty pop singing politicians that get pretty far,
but we recognize them.
We know they're bullshit artists.
We hear speeches,
these canned fucking who we Rah Rah Sarah Pailin style speeches,
and we go,
that's a pop star that says a shitty one at that.
There's gotta be some real leader out there.
You know what I'm saying?
That someone who is not following a mold,
but speaking from the heart,
somebody truly doesn't give a fuck.
They must exist and if they don't,
it's possible.
The gunner,
fear and loathing on the campaign trail 72 yep.
That's the book.
That's great fucking book.
Yeah,
I read part of it.
Shark hunting was a good one.
Yeah.
His I'm crucified documentary who explains like the creation of all this stuff,
like how he became an embedded reporter was so fascinating that he was like one
guy at all.
These guys that had nothing to lose because he knew he'd never do this again.
So he just was fucking going bonkers on PT Barnum all he talked football and got
his way into Nixon's car.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy?
Sitting with Nixon,
the ride of the airport,
Hunter Thompson talking football and they made sure you're only going to talk
football now.
None.
None of the Vietnam stuff and they just talked football.
That would be bizarre.
Is Fuck be sitting there with Nixon
with,
I mean,
just the biggest hidden agenda ever.
You know,
snowball and the president of the fucking United States.
No,
you're going to rip his ass hole wide apart in a book.
Yeah.
Right.
Complete and total character studies.
Well he was one of the most incredibly bizarre former presidents.
He's a very odd guy.
Do you see that book?
There's written out that they believe he was gay and then is,
uh,
this guy that he's with her sometime was his boyfriend.
So the same thing about Lincoln though.
Did they?
Yeah,
but didn't like sleep with men to stay warm.
His bodyguard sub in his body under service agent,
they shared a bed and it's now it's speculated that they had a relationship due
to some,
some journal memoirs they found or small law.
You can justify us just about anything.
Who Cares?
Who gives a shit?
We could do,
we could do well with the gay president,
you know,
maybe even better could be,
there'd be some empathy there.
Maybe,
maybe not.
You know,
Julius Caesar was gay and I'm saying Alexander the Great was gay.
A lot of fucking gay warriors as people like to sleep on gay people.
Fuck you up to.
I would always have to fight a gay dude.
Whoop your ass man.
Meaning Shit.
Nixon's darkest secrets do biography digs up.
Rumors.
Richard Nixon's gay affair with Mafia banker.
That's the guy.
Yeah,
the guy.
I'm just going to say yes.
I'm looking at the two of them together for sure.
Who knows?
Maybe Nixon didn't like to fuck anybody but America.
He probably was one of those things who,
it wasn't a,
it didn't have a gender,
sexual,
he was nation sexual.
Just wanting to fuck America like a kindle.
He just didn't have any.
Yeah.
It wasn't nothing.
Just just evil thoughts.
Well,
he was a different,
it's different breed back then.
Different breed of politician and post.
I mean he's coming along post Kennedy's assassination and bizarre dark time in
America.
That was,
well,
it's,
that's when they can lock it all down.
That's when the,
all the scheduled warm lists started popping up.
Everything kind of,
yeah.
That again,
that's a valley.
You know,
I mean,
there was a great hill.
The Great Hill was like the 1960s and then the 70s came along and that was the
big valley and that's where disco came from.
That's what happened.
Nobody had acid,
nobody had mushrooms,
just cocaine,
man.
Just dance and fuel and all that bad judgment.
Just like,
it's like eighties country.
Bad judgment,
but so good fucking music.
You know?
If it wasn't for disco,
you wouldn't have kool and the gang.
Right.
And that's where I came from.
That's all dancing.
Music and bgs mean.
Yeah,
they go,
dude,
they had some good jams.
Seriously.
Good job they do.
Right.
People don't want to admit that I,
yeah.
Wasn't a woman.
Come on,
it's good God damn song.
Jamie's going to disagree.
That's a shame.
Yeah.
There even the stones stuck their foot in the disco water.
Yeah,
for sure.
There was some funk to a lot of their songs that didn't exist in the earlier
music.
They were creating products at the time was man.
Yeah.
What's Today's time?
I mean,
what,
when you,
when you see this new door opening up for you,
you know,
when you say like all of a sudden your,
your career,
like you said,
you've called your way to the beginning.
You're obviously,
there's some shit going on man.
I mean I told you my friend Justin told me about your right when he goes,
man,
he goes,
this is dude Sturgill Simpson.
And as soon as he said that I go,
I tell you I've been listening to nothing but him for two fucking weeks and we
were laughing and joking around.
There's something going on man.
Well my friend Justin finds out about shit.
I always pay attention cause he's got fantastic taste in music.
But I had already found out like there's,
there's something going on and you've,
you've hit this sort of frequency where people are checking out your shit.
Six weeks would be over tomorrow,
man.
Yeah,
but it's not going to be,
let's be honest,
this stitch shit's gonna ride just hanging there fella.
All right,
well I've got,
I've got a very clear plan.
Do you?
No matter what,
I'm going to adhere to it.
And so we want to tell us the plan or is it secret shit,
this is not really a secret.
No,
I just,
I'm gonna make,
I'm gonna make a total of five records and then that's it and be done.
Why?
I feel like,
well,
I want,
I want them,
there's a,
there's a certain methodology to the entire thing,
but,
uh,
I don't know.
I think a lot of,
I don't know what else I would have to say beyond that.
Um,
and each one successfully kind of incorporate other elements of music that I
love and am to get more progressively opened up.
And so you've got this mapped up like in a formal way,
roughly.
Yeah.
Do you have it written down somewhere
in various forms?
Voice memos and notes and things,
but yeah,
I mean,
the idea that just,
just to lay out and in the sonic execution.
Um,
but then beyond that,
a lot of,
a lot of artists keep recording in order to maintain some sense of relevancy or,
you know,
or just because,
well,
it's been a year's time to make a record.
I just don't ever want to find myself in that position where I'm,
um,
I don't know.
I think I would keep,
I'd rather keep it more concise and focused and just try to do,
to know that I absolutely did my best every time.
And then I think after five albums,
I don't know,
I'll probably,
I already feel somewhat limited in terms of songwriting and how much freedom
there is to really get out what you want to say.
So I don't know,
I might try something else at some point.
Like just writing outright,
like writing a book or,
yeah,
so just looking at it as another form of expression.
But I,
I think it's a weird that you like think that you're going to run dry.
Like what makes you think you want?
I want,
I'm going to one dry.
Oh,
it's not an,
it's not an issue of running dry,
just,
uh,
certain things that I want to say
or,
you know,
make a statement with,
use the opportunity to,
to hopefully make it other than something just about me,
you know,
try to promote a bigger message,
I guess.
So.
And at some point you just end up repeating yourself.
That's fascinating.
I hope that's wrong.
I hope you just keep banging them out and having a good time,
but you're the only one that knows what's going on in your head.
You know,
you're the only one who's ever going to know your vision.
Right.
So there's a real job was just
keeping myself out of a situation wherever I have to compromise that.
That's fascinating though,
that you've done that.
Then you have this idea of these stages that you're going to put out.
So you're only going to put out three more albums or five more.
Three more,
that's it.
But you've been doing music for how many years now?
My whole life,
but I mean professionally for two albums will professionally really just like
the last two years I've put my first record out in 2013 okay,
so two years for two albums.
So it's an that almost an album a year.
So you only got three more years ago and then what are you going to do?
I have no idea.
Oh,
come on man.
Just keep making music.
Han and Toucan in the jungle or something.
Do you plan on doing that?
Like expanding your horizons and some sort of great and unforeseen way by not
doing this?
When I was younger,
I was out doing a lot of other things that kind of culminated into whoever the
hell I think I'm trying to be today.
Right?
So incorporating those experiences and a lot of the stories and people I've
known and characters I've met,
and then maybe even embellishing upon that in a somewhat autobiographical
sentence,
but still telling these stories in a way that other people say,
yeah,
I feel that way too.
You know?
You don't want to just say,
hey,
this is what the world looks like.
It's just this is what it looks like to me.
And hopefully other people can can resonate with that.
But it's an interesting,
okay,
there's a line you have to really kind of straddled between commercial because
commercial viability and
making art.
Does this a a rigid idea that you have or do you think that it's possible that
you could get to that three albums from now and then go,
you know what,
I'm enjoying the fucking shit out of this.
I'm not going to stop.
I'm just going to figure out a new concept.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to go Chris Gaines on put on,
no,
this kid,
is that his name?
Chris Kane.
Kane's to Garth Brooks character.
Maybe that's what he was doing.
Well,
I mean,
outside of that,
I think I've already,
well,
I say that just because I have
those albums pretty clearly in my head and I deal with those sound like and what
they'll be about and
does,
you know,
someday you're dead.
Everybody that ever knew he was dead and it's like you were never here,
but that little thing,
I don't know what else I would really have to say about,
hmm,
my version of the human experience past a certain point.
Unless I go turn it off and do another 30 or 40 years of living and then make
five alums.
Any real artists,
their best work is always in their,
in their pinnacle peak and then right before they die.
And then you get this,
this,
okay
ocean of mediocrity of just kind of fumbling through existence there.
It says it's,
is it very repeated element.
That's an interesting perspective because you really think that when a guy puts
out an album or these parallels to authors to a lot of different art form blue,
you spent your entire life thinking and then you express yourself like the
culmination of this life and your first few pieces of it
work.
Well,
there's a really interesting thing of somebody,
I think Jay and my buddy Jason has built,
put up there,
didn't retweet it,
talks about you.
It takes 20 years to write your first record.
You get a year to write your second record and a really,
doesn't matter what you do because music's the devil's work and you're fucked
anyway.
But,
um,
but yeah,
it's like,
you know,
you squeeze all this.
I had,
I had a good 30 years of,
of fucking up and mistakes and lessons and,
and you know,
a lot of personal,
you own your own development and certain experiences that I had that led me to
kind of recognize and look at things that cause me to live that way.
And then to come out the other side of that,
like really supported and understood by someone that met me at my absolute worst
and then help me to get right here.
It's just like I have all this clarity now and you know,
I think the only way
to ever really grab that fee,
I mean,
I probably could have made some great records in my twenties because I was so
fucked up.
You know,
it I'll never know,
but,
so I'm just trying to like reference those feelings as I remember them the best
I can.
And People Think,
oh,
I made this record,
this guy just sitting around fucking smoking DMT and he's on drugs and we didn't
have it.
There were no drugs involved in making this record.
Uh,
it's been,
you know,
I really don't even smoke dope that much anymore.
Especially with the sun.
Certainly not when I'm at home,
usually on the road and it's only them anymore to cure boredom.
MMM.
So it's just really weird to find myself,
but I still had to tell that part of my life through stories.
When you were,
when you were in your 20s,
you were partying a lot.
I wouldn't even say partying.
Um,
it was always more exploratory for me.
I never had an addictive personality,
but I never,
I don't know.
I,
I've,
I just read a lot of the wrong books way too young and had this weird romantic
orientation that everything was encapsulated under the umbrella of experience
and I wanted to experience everything.
And some things you just shouldn't experience and they get a,
I mean,
whatever man,
in whatever's in front of me or I could find,
I just never,
I always just wanted to know,
you know?
MMM.
Say when I got out of the navy,
living in Seattle,
that was,
those were some darker days,
you know?
Okay.
Well you were saying that earlier that about Seattle,
not just being the weather,
what the weather does to people.
At some
point,
I just became very disenchanted disillusioned with the military.
So I got out and it stuck around there for like a year.
So there's that disenchantment of disillusionment and then there's living in
Seattle where you're dealing with the dreariness at the same time,
mid uh,
a really kind of,
you know,
it was excited as this young relationship and I was going all of these parties
and meeting people and,
and expose the things I probably never would have been otherwise and just Kinda,
you know,
took it at face value for experience and jumped in.
And then there was a lot of,
you know,
there's a lot hard narcotics in that area and I realized that those weren't very
well for me.
And heroin,
heroin,
methamphetamine,
every,
anything you're looking for really cut wherever you can grab her forward.
And I couldn't,
I wasn't 21 I couldn't go out and drink.
So there was all these other methods of escapism that I kind of fell into.
And I got really bad off for a while.
And actually as a result,
I ended up missing my grandfather's funeral cause I was,
I knew if I came home,
like my family would come,
my dad used to be an undercover narcotics officer.
So he,
you know,
there was some weird,
a lot of shame there after that,
you know what I mean?
So eventually ended up back in Kentucky and got away from that.
And then it was just really just,
I don't know,
man.
I never really was a very ambitious guy,
just sort of drifted and existed a lot.
And uh,
I dunno if something,
it was more of exploratory just because I knew there was something else
beyond whatever this is.
I mean,
that's what I was trying to find.
Now how did you get involved with,
uh,
Rick Strassman?
How'd you find out about them and how'd you meet him?
Like I said,
my buddy played when we were talking about
porch last year and then he played your little excerpts and I went home that
night,
just kind of scars scar on the Internet,
on,
on the subjects and a lot of things related to it.
And I found dark Strassman's book,
download it and read it it probably three times.
And it just like,
it just absolutely blew my mind.
Um,
all the correlating aspects of this commerce of that conversation.
And I think what might have ultimately led him to it or what he was looking for
in terms of its relation to,
you should have him on Sunday and how it's to be on.
So is it okay?
Yeah,
he's going to be on soon to promote the new book.
When,
what date,
Jamie?
12th 12th.
We had a great conversation in his kitchen about five days ago and he was very
gracious enough to invite me out and um,
cause I read there in very nice guy.
Oh,
extremely.
I mean,
he's a cool dude.
He's just so sweet.
Probably would never think that in cell,
but he's like,
in so many ways it was,
I'm really glad I went and um,
and it answered a lot of questions and even questions I didn't even know I had.
But it's interesting to find out why he approached it and what he got.
He probably knows more than anybody else on the subject at this point.
But he's,
he's like,
he's like a musician that has been touring a record for a year.
He's so tired of talking about this is all 25 ago
he's moved on.
But um,
people are still finding out about it.
So it's,
yeah,
people like,
no,
fairly obscure,
although his,
for his day to day existence,
it's been like,
it's sort of a overwhelmed as day to day existence for the past 20 plus years.
But for a lot of folks,
they're just starting to read his work
in the email the other day.
He's like,
so yeah,
once I've finished the record and had it mixed and mastered,
I'm sort of like looking back through all the,
everything that sort of led to this happening.
And I knew I went into it before we put the album and I really did think,
okay,
well this is going to be the end of March.
You know,
um,
people are going to think this guy's nuts for what the hell happened.
But you know,
but hit the work that the doctors Strassman did.
And I guess the bravery it took on his part to open that conversation back up in
a,
in a field,
especially in the,
in the professional medical world,
was so stigmatized.
Um,
I can't imagine like the balls that must've taken after spending years of your
life following this,
this professional school he underwent.
And so I wrote him an email and I got the,
I got his contact off cotton when I just wrote him,
basically say,
Hey,
thank you.
I wrote a shared the record with him through a file.
It was just like,
I just wanted to thanks for your work and the inspiration that I got from the
book and along with some other things.
And he wrote back and it sort of,
you know,
email buddies sort of thing.
And then,
uh,
I was going out to Phoenix and so I just stopped by,
I have a cup of coffee
just like anybody else,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
He's just a regular guy,
but he's a,
he's a,
he's got some really fascinating stories of his explorations in this realm.
Uh,
not just physically,
but just dealing with the red tape that was required to do a real FDA study.
Two years of credit nightmare man.
Yeah.
To do one of the first psychedelic studies that,
you know,
have a real scholar involved in testing people on some serious schedule.
One hallucinogens that the army research labs,
they were where they were aware of that shit in the 60s.
Absolutely.
They had 'em.
That's how Mckenna found out about it.
Terence Mckenna got ahold of DMT through a friend who was a chemist at the army
research lab and apparently this guy had,
they had like a barrel roll of it.
Oh yeah.
Which if you know about the effective dose of DMTs about like a pinky nail is a
lot.
Like if you had a pinky nail sized piece of DMT or pile,
you might as level of football stadium of weed you're going,
you're getting blasted mean you're going to the center of the fucking universe
with a pinky size.
So imagine these guys had barrels of stuff and um,
Mckenna's store,
I found out about mechanics because of Hicks.
Hicks,
Rhett Rep mentioned Mckenna on one of his bits.
What Terrence me,
he would talk,
talk about taping mushrooms under the chair of everybody in the room.
Like he would like say something and then he would drag them into this.
I've taped mushrooms under all your chairs.
Reached down is what Terence Mckenna would call a heroic dose,
five dried grams,
you know,
and um,
I was like,
who is this mechanic guy?
And so,
uh,
I started looking into Mckenna and reading,
some of the things that I could find about him online and then listening to some
audio recordings.
But he was a,
he was already dead,
but by the time I had found out about them,
unfortunately,
but his,
you know,
his discovery of DMT and the way he described it,
and one of his audio recordings was just one of the most amazing things I've
ever heard because this is a guy who had already done like LSD and morning glory
seeds and needed to experience psilocybin.
And he thought he had
really traveled.
He thought he kind of knew what was available in Allentown.
Did this,
they did a little traveling.
I guess put a man and like the Boga and like I said,
DMT out of mine won't really have any experience to speak of firsthand.
So I try not to talk about it.
We've got to change that.
We've got to hook that up.
Hey Man.
Allegedly,
well,
you know,
doctor [inaudible] said that,
and I,
I'm inclined to agree with,
although at this point,
like after I should have a fucking phd in this shit.
I've read about it and I don't even know what the firsthand aspect is,
but uh,
he said at this point in my life now that all these things are formulating in my
careers,
budding and have a newborn son,
that there's a high potential who could make for a pretty unsettling experience.
Cause it's all this stuff that's finally happening in my life.
It's so positive.
Like the idea of thinking you're dying and having to let go.
That could be make for an unsettling,
you'll be fine.
Yeah.
I believe you.
He'll be fine.
I mean,
I've had some,
some,
I wouldn't say heroic as a foolish dosage.
You know,
the first time you ever,
you ever buy mushrooms,
everybody's there to tell you,
hey will,
this is how much it takes.
You know?
So I think I bought like a quarter and just ate the whole bag mans and that was
my first,
I mean,
what does that accelerate salary grahams.
Whoa.
How was that?
That was great time,
man.
I,
you know,
I never,
I never got the freak outs except,
uh,
well that's good.
Do you have a good soul?
You've towns?
I tried LSD though.
I didn't really enjoy it because it all,
every time it seemed like on the tail end of the trip there's,
there's this,
it takes this turn and there's almost this almost a sinister underlying energy
about it.
I don't know,
that I'd never experienced with silicide.
Um,
so Simon's very giggly.
Yeah.
And that's a lot of people selling.
It's like,
it's the starting gate for psychedelics.
And I add to that,
I say,
go eat 12 or 15 grams and telling me that you're,
yeah,
the starting gate is only if you have a small,
it's overwhelming.
It's completely overweight.
And it also
very,
very visionary like you see,
I remember,
um,
just seeing Stan hope and I did mushrooms the day war
started the day the Iraq war started.
We,
we the first one or the first one,
not,
not uh,
an eighties,
you know,
the,
the one after nine 11.
Gotcha.
And um,
we were blitzed as they were on television.
The war was starting and I'll never forget standing up was like,
oh my God,
they've got a kickoff.
They're like,
war coverage begins at five.
He's like,
war has a kickoff.
And we just fell to the ground,
were howling and laughing and this,
the walls around this,
we're all made of like these honeycomb geometric patterns.
Like everything was basically gone.
I go was trying to still have conversations with him,
but he was just this sea of patterns,
you know,
that like blur really represented what his physical form was.
But it was all just like really tiny flower of loves,
you know,
that little flower of life thing.
It was like,
sir,
I mean,
that was his,
his entire body was made out of those,
as was all the walls around us.
I mean it's,
it's almost identical to dimethyltryptamine in the molecular footprint,
right?
So it's pretty close to take a high dose
for Fox for a [inaudible] trip.
Tryptamines how it's been explained.
I think what happens is I'm extra oxygen does.
Others were obviously not chemists,
ladies and gentlemen,
we are not studying the periodic table.
If you read Strassman's accounts of it,
there's,
there's um,
where they talk about how it's synthesized in the body.
It's very similar.
It's got a lot of the same elements as real natural human neurotransmitters.
So it's very easily accepted into the mind.
The blood brain barrier accepts that a crazy well,
yeah,
I mean dimethyltryptamine for sure.
We know that.
We know that it's cool.
We didn't know and it's created in the liver.
It's creating the lungs.
It's not just creating the pineal gland created another parts of your body.
They also know that it's in like,
you know,
who knows how many fucking plants,
like a shit load of plants.
So that's just out there.
It's all over the place.
I,
you know,
I think it's cool that guys like humor out there.
So important.
I know I've had some unbelievably profound introspectively healing experiences,
especially for mushrooms on the high dose get minutes.
It really forces you to look at a lot of things.
Maybe you don't want to have your own able to and just kind of pulls apart the
defense mechanism,
you know,
destroying the ego.
The one thing that allows people to push forward in spite of
or because of everything that they've learned their whole life,
this to built up defense mechanisms,
the buildup up definitions of yourself and then you know,
you're pushing forward with all this stuff attached to you.
Like it's like an armor,
but really you find out that that's really the shit that's kind of holding your
perspective back.
And if you release all that armor and just look around and release this idea of
you and then just experience,
it's a very different world you're living in that that different world is rarely
tapped into in,
in regular life.
But that different world resets your entire perspective of your existence.
And if that's not good for you,
what the fuck is everybody doing?
Meditating?
Why is everybody going to church?
Why is everybody going to workshops and try it?
There were trying to get better.
Everyone's trying to get better.
I've never seen a single thing in life that has the same effects that
psychedelic drugs do.
And yet they're illegal.
I mean,
the,
it's one of the weirdest aspects of our time that these things have these
unbelievably profound effects,
but they're illegal.
Whereas there's,
you know,
x number of sanction drugs that don't have these effects that are deadly
[inaudible],
asshole bleed and everything else sell that shit all day.
I mean,
they're trying to crack down now on the prescriptions.
I'm on pain,
pain medication,
prescriptions because it has so many people that are addicted to them and
they've realized,
look,
we've made a nation of junkies.
It's,
I mean,
I'll tell you the party of the country you're from,
and I mean that,
that is fucking,
that is prescription drug central,
right?
Hillbilly heroin,
man.
It's unbelievable.
It's right.
I mean,
the town that I'm originally from,
uh,
it's called Jackson.
It's like right in the middle of Southeast Kentucky,
like Appalachia.
And I remember as a small child,
it was very much,
it was a wonderful community.
There were small business,
main street was thriving,
everybody knew everybody.
Um,
and then,
but all the major industry was based on coal,
which slowly evolved from strip mining or from deep mining,
I'm sorry,
into strip mining.
Once they figured out they could get the coal with less bodies.
And uh,
so that just kind of leveled the topography.
But then even when that industry sort of dried up and they moved on,
well the coal pulled out and then Walmart and oxycotton moved in and it,
I mean within a matter of years it just completely changed the entire face of,
of the region.
Wow.
And now it's just,
you know,
like why people say poor you don't even have a fucking poor is man,
and,
and there's,
there's,
there's a,
it's sad because there's no,
okay,
there's not even the idea of like the,
the possibility of opportunity coming to that region,
you know,
nothing.
No industry is going to come in there and like start building car manufacturing
plants.
Cause then they have to train the shit out of there.
It's just not logistically very sound for any type of industry other than
growing dope and making Meth,
you know,
uh,
like it,
unless they really pushed the hemp legislation through and then they can put a
lot of money and food on people's tables down there.
But I,
it would be incredible.
[inaudible] either they're really finally pushing toward it.
I'll never thought I'd say this,
but there's a guy named Mitch Mcconnell's for once did something I agree with
and uh,
he's really trying to get that Kentucky was at one time the late the nation's
leading him manufacturing point of the hemp museums and little town called
Versailles.
Lot of interesting things in Kentucky.
Kentucky reintroduced elk.
Yeah.
And they have a giant successful herds of elk.
I mean,
there are hunting them now.
They reintroduced them.
They've done it over a period of a few decades.
They used to have elk,
all crossings.
It was illegal for a long time.
Timed to out in Kentucky.
And then they,
and I guess they're getting the population to kind of grow back.
Well,
there was none.
There were none.
The Rocky Mountain elk foundation brought elk in and they,
they,
they sort of seeded the area and now it's become very successful and now they
have hunt.
Hmm.
Well there used to be a lot of elk.
Yes.
There's a care that in the Daniel Boone days,
Davy Crockett days,
you know the shit out of it.
How did the shit out of him?
Yeah.
It's,
but it's interesting that Kentucky on the ball with hemp as well,
right.
Bacco industry took a big hit and that really hurts the state economy and then
they have to do something I hope.
Does hope really that's what becomes the the next day cause farmer and it will
change the consciousness to you will,
you know,
that's going to go and Du Pont and all the petroleum industries and everybody
else start throwing more money at making it not happening.
That's why.
That's why it was elite elite.
You know?
I wonder if they're going to be it.
Yeah.
That is why it was made illegal in the first place.
But I wonder if they're going to be able to do that because I feel like they
even,
they don't have enough resources to stop that kind of truth forever.
Right.
It's already come out and what you've seen with what's going on in Colorado is
even Warren Buffet's companies are getting in on it.
Warren Buffet,
Warren Buffet has a company that leases giant warehouses specifically to weed
growers.
They have commercials where they're there.
They're showing how they have these tiered systems where there's a like second
floor and first floor.
He could fit in more weed plants than a single for warehouse.
This is Warren motherfucking buffet and his company is involved and actively
pursuing marijuana growers to lease their warehouses to grow marijuana because
it's legal there.
So it becomes a part of,
yeah.
Is it going to be big corporations that are profiting on it?
Maybe,
but guess what,
it's not hard to grow.
Right.
You know,
it's not hard.
I mean it's,
it's,
this is not creating oxycontin's and some sort of fucking laboratory.
We have to wear a space suit.
You know,
you're,
you're talking about a plant that grows like that.
You don't even have to do anything to it.
Just take it in the ground and come back in a month.
You get some shit grow in there.
It's super easy.
I mean it is a hard,
you know,
hard to fuck up really.
It's hard to fuck up.
I mean you could do it better.
You can make the kind of weed that there's botanists,
motherfuckers in California and Colorado and Washington state
versus when it does eventually when you know like everything else,
at some point it is going to go mainstream and then they're going to commodify
the hell out of it and commercialize it.
And everywhere you go is going to look like a 14 year old's bedroom.
And this is the Warren Buffet's company.
Look at this.
Cuba,
what does it's called cross crawl.
So we could see it so we could see the name of the company,
cubic designs.
So this is like see how he's get these tiered systems that is entirely for
fucking grown wheat.
Wow.
We're going to go tour in Washington state when we play.
I love it.
I think it's amazing.
I think the corporations are going to get in on it,
but I don't think they're going to be able to control it.
I just think something like weed is too easy to grow.
You've definitely,
they're definitely gonna make a lot of money.
They could definitely get exclusive deals with certain providers and stores.
Maybe they can make it difficult to have a license to own a store where you
could sell a shitload of it,
but if it's legal,
people are going to grow it.
They're going to grow their own,
they're going to grow neighborhood growing weed operations,
and if they do allow small businesses to grow it.
I think the laws at stated today is that you have to grow the marijuana and then
sell it.
You can't buy like you couldn't grow it and then sell it to me and,
and I buy it and sell.
Okay.
I couldn't,
I couldn't do that.
I would have to grow my own and sell my own.
So you have to be a grower as well as a dealer,
which is fine.
I mean that's a small group of people could,
you know,
cultivate a large amount of marijuana and make a shit load of money.
That's good.
Saw this really not too long episode of vice where they were looking at the
industry and yeah,
he's,
I guess they're not allowed to use banks in Colorado.
They're showing these starting to change blackwater guys escorting the payouts
every day and shit.
I was just like,
holy,
you know,
you're going know you're consider that aspect.
How much money they probably took out of the cartels hands the first few years.
I mean,
oh yeah.
Fuck yeah.
It'll be interesting to see what this all really turns into.
I wonder if people will remain positive,
you know.
Well,
it's too much money,
right?
Too much money.
Yeah,
it is.
It's a curious thing because it's extremely profitable and it's current and
people are aware of the profitability of it.
People are aware of that.
Not only that,
they're aware that traffic,
uh,
incidents of pulling people over for Duis is at an all time low.
Murder is dropped,
everything's dropped,
violent crime dropped.
I mean you're showing a huge increase in the amount of money that's being
generated as far as like for state revenue more than a hundred million dollars
in taxes this year and then you're showing these drops in crime drops in Duis,
drops in murder,
like there's nothing you could say other than what's,
let's try this somewhere else.
Any state that struggling and he state that doesn't have some sort of a massive
resource pool like a natural oil or gas or something like that that's relying on
if they are in need of an industry,
boy that's a fucking pretty easy one.
It's right there for you.
Dive on.
Ambitious.
You can make some money three months from now,
just going to make you some more money all over again.
I wonder what's going to happen.
I wonder how many states are going adopt at this this next upcoming election.
I would imagine it's going to be another couple.
At least I would like to see five or six more.
Just jump in and start just wildly.
You know,
it'd be the shit if Texas jumped in.
Utah was talking about it are really,
you know,
because the Mormons figured out,
well if we can make a fuck ton of money off of this too is,
I mean if you talk,
I was talking about it then I can't,
I mean I,
I think the south will still be the last part of the country where it ever
materializes.
Does a lot of fucking stoners in Utah manages a lot of stoners in Utah.
I was in Utah,
did a Salt Lake City.
I did 'em Salt Lake City is a really liberal town,
which is weird.
The,
the,
I think they all kind of moved out to the outskirts.
So now you've got this little hotbed of a rebellion right there in the middle of
it all.
You know,
wiseguys comedy club that places the Shit and it's right in Salt Lake and all my
friends who worked there,
they all come back.
Go Do,
if you've been to salt lake is the best kept secret in the United States.
Oh,
it's fucking banging.
They're nice people too,
man.
That is a nice town.
And
there's a lot of weed going around Utah.
If they grow it to they're going to start seeing massive amounts of profit and
they're going to see a shift in consciousness.
That's the big thing.
The shift in consciousness,
they might take a few more years to recognize that and the effects of that,
but people were just going to be nicer.
It's just going to happen.
You can't,
you can't smoke a ton of weed and keep the entire population with the same anger
level that's going to change.
It'll change the way people interact with each other and that won't taint,
that will in turn change the entire culture.
The genie's out of the bottle.
You don't really see fights breaking out in coffee shops in Amsterdam.
It's not.
It's very rare.
Very rare.
Yeah,
but oddly enough,
a lot of Jujitsu guys like to smoke.
Weed really didn't go.
Did you Jitsu?
Bruce was a big pothead with me.
Yeah.
I used to eat hash.
I thought that that killed him.
I remember when I was a teenager.
Is that bullshit?
They said his brain swelled from the hash.
Yeah.
He apparently had a head injury and yeah,
I think he also had some sort of a reaction to the drugs he was taking for it.
I should probably Google that.
I think you're writing,
Linda gave him something for his anyway.
Yeah.
You just get,
he's just get stone as hell workout all day,
right?
Yeah.
He loved Hash apparently.
Apparently he was really into it,
man.
Um,
but if you've ever eaten hash,
we kind of get it.
The,
the eating of marijuana is one of the least respected,
but most ass kicking of all the psychedelic experiences of prefer edibles.
Yeah,
man.
The shit that they're throwing around today,
there's these dude called Los hormonals.
The gummies that the,
that the name of them.
Gooney brothers.
Yeah.
These motherfuckers,
my friend Ari had this comedy central taping and these guys showed up,
but these gummy bears and then they,
I go,
I'm looking at the gummy bear.
It's a bear.
I go,
how much did I eat?
And the guy goes,
no more than the head.
I'm like,
well,
why are you making it so big?
Why?
What do you mean no more than the head?
What happens if I eat more than the head?
He's like,
don't do it.
Don't why you made it.
You made it.
Joey Diaz,
he's the whole fucking
thing.
Oh Man.
He's a hero.
It's a man amongst men.
We were out here months ago for this,
uh,
played with Gregg Allman down at the Annenberg Center and some guy came or
somebody gave us these little man,
they were tiny.
They were like these little tiny little cupcake with like a piece on the top of
the no bigger than a nickel.
And um,
it just absolutely destroyed me.
It wasn't,
I had to somehow find my way back to my hotel room just to lay down and just,
it was,
there was nothing fun about it.
I was completely nonfunctional.
Um,
the Saturday night at 8:00 PM and I was just done.
Okay.
Yeah.
They're saying that Bruce Lee's brain had been swollen.
Uh,
when they checked his autopsy they said there was no visible external injury.
However,
according to autopsy reports,
his brain,
it's swollen considerably from 1400 to 1,575 grams,
which is a 13% increase,
which is pretty big.
He was only 32 the only substance found during his autopsy was equally Jessic.
I don't know what that is.
Um,
I'll Google it.
Okay.
The only subset.
The doctor said in an interview that he's,
he died from an allergic reaction to the muscle.
Relax,
an equal just stick whatever it is,
which described as a common ingredient and painkillers.
Doctors announced neat Lee's death officially it was ruled death by
misadventure.
Huh.
Wow.
That's interesting.
But I guarantee he had some head injuries
cause he was sparring,
you know,
look if you're,
if you're doing the kind of shit that he was doing,
he was experimenting a lot with various martial arts and how to most likely he
got hit.
I mean that's just a part of the game.
And if he was doing really experimental wild stuff,
like I know he was involved in a lot of different sort of assimilating a lot of
different martial arts style.
Oh sure.
Dan Inosanto got a shot or two and then,
yeah,
all of them,
you know,
there's a,
there's some recent video,
a recently released video of him sparring at some,
uh,
some karate tournament thing,
and he has his head gear on his full body armor on,
and he,
him,
this dude had going at it.
So if he was involved and stuff like that,
and he's most likely he's getting hit in the head.
It's just the way it is.
He worked with a lot of boxers.
I know he worked with gene,
the bell,
he did some judo with gene.
And it's just the nature of martial arts,
especially when you're involved in striking sports.
So who knows?
Who knows what it was?
It caused his head to bleed,
but it wasn't eating hash.
No.
That's a shame.
Have you gotten a hold of some of the La,
um,
edibles while you're here?
Uh,
this trip?
No.
Yes,
you have.
You just don't know it yet.
11 in the last experience kind of put me off,
dude.
I'm not kidding.
That fucking cupcake.
And we,
all three of us were done.
I mean they,
they don't,
they gotta put a dosage
that shit they do now.
They put numbers on.
It was not cool.
I mean it was just not,
not night.
My night was over.
Well they have this,
um,
they have these things called Chiba Chews and some of them,
I think we're up to 250 milligrams,
which is just insane and effective dose.
It's like 20 or 30 and the same like 2020 is not bad for like a mellow,
easygoing body.
High 30.
You're pushing the boundaries of paranoia.
40 50.
You're in a cold sweat to 50.
Joey Dsa,
two of them.
It was a chocolate bar to place they go to,
it's 40 dos games,
40 doses in one chocolate bar.
What the fuck man?
How big?
It's small.
Small,
not a big bar,
you know,
worth like five pieces,
right?
Like how many inches wide sneaker size,
40 doses.
40 people.
I mean,
whatever magic you made it by yourself.
Two hits.
And it's like,
cause you want to see Buddha,
right?
There's only one way to see you.
Gotta Close Your Eyes,
shut the lights out and watch the dance.
Yeah,
I don't know.
So at some point
while like I realize like,
oh,
I start almost felt like I was getting anxiety from smoking it and it definitely
the carcinogen and as a singer now I got to really got to be cautious about,
so I just Kinda quit smoking.
And then the edibles,
it's,
you're right.
It's an entirely different feeling.
It's more of an anti anxiety,
almost like an overall body high.
Whereas if you try to go out on stage,
I can't,
I can't smoke and perform cause it's like you get so internalized,
I feel like I can't connect with the crowd at all.
Um,
so I just learned a long time ago not,
not to do that.
Um,
but with the edibles man,
it almost just opens you up,
opens you up and it's much more expressive.
I think it
do you know about the,
uh,
conversion in your body?
Like 11 hydroxy metabolite people who have heard this on the podcast?
Please bear with me.
I know you've heard this.
Um,
when you eat marijuana,
it produces something called 11 hydroxy metabolite is it passes through your
liver and apparently it's four to five times more psychoactive than THC.
Oh,
absolutely.
That's why it's such an intensely different experience.
It's because it's a totally different drug.
When you select a trophic,
I mean,
yeah.
Well in this,
in the sense we depth tank,
sensory deprivation tank,
it's very psychedelic when you eat it because you,
you just,
you're in that the experience,
which is so bizarre as it is.
Yeah.
You don't even really need drugs and those things do.
No,
you don't need anything.
We'll sell.
You have one.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Want to do it?
How long are you here for?
I fly out tomorrow at noon.
See what we can do.
You should try it though.
Some point in your life for sure.
I don't know if they have one in Nashville,
but they're,
they're popping up all over the country.
They had one in DC when I was in DC.
Had people from the show in Philly,
the,
they have one in Philly.
It's like they're showing up all over the country cause we're starting to open
up these tank tank centers.
And this is another thing that didn't,
didn't exist in most cities.
It was hard to find more.
I mean,
you got to maintain the Ph levels and
mine has a full filtrate.
I have a commercial level one,
Nashville float,
Nashville,
Bam sign.
You're in.
Who,
who,
who?
I work on buying a car first and you don't,
it's not expensive.
I mean you don't have to have one.
You go and rent went out,
just go and uh,
you know,
seven appointment,
you should definitely try it.
It's one of the most profound feelings of relaxation.
Yeah.
Complete and total disassociation experience.
You're like,
you can't,
you lose feeling of your body.
Yeah.
You don't think you're there anymore.
You think your mind has been released from your body and your mind's flying
through space.
Completely untethered from the body.
You don't feel the water.
The only time I've ever experienced that.
Uh,
even on,
I never had any type of complete disassociation experiences,
even though I come home and really high doses,
just silicide the one time I ever,
I think what I would class was the most psychedelic experience I've ever had was
from a drug that's not even normally associated with psychedelic fan,
which Dextromethorphan DXM it's,
it's a lot of kids like pound bottles of Robitussin to get,
I mean by the time you consume enough DXM ruts in the road test and you're,
you're doing so much horrible shit to your body.
Um,
but I,
I only,
I only encountered at one time,
we were at this festival in Charlotte,
North Carolina.
Friend of mine had somehow gotten a hold of,
this is pure medical grade Dextromethorphan and we had a digital scale of Gel
cap swinging it out and it's about 400 milligrams.
It's just the most amazing,
completely inexplicable experience I've ever had from.
Wow.
Um,
my,
my buddy Brian,
he's like,
you know,
stores,
you need to hear music on this.
And he's like,
it's as good as it fucking gets.
So first off,
this is the weirdest part of the whole experiences were what were out in this
Koa campground in North Carolina.
They're just surrounded by hippies and there's night,
you know,
tanks going off and shit and like that ain't my thing.
But tanks.
Yeah,
igniters tanks from the company's Hippie Festival.
He meant like,
no,
no.
I understand.
Um,
hip stuff.
We had to make it back down to the parking lot where his truck was parked
through the,
through this trail.
You couldn't see shit man.
It was like the most complete flood or vision ever.
And I'm just stumbling,
not walking into trees.
And Brian was like,
oh,
maybe just close your eyes.
Like,
what are you talking about?
We talk about close mine.
He's like,
you just close your eyes.
Trust me in that,
close my eyes.
And I,
I,
she swears I'm sitting here.
It was all of a sudden,
like I could see the trail plain as day directly in front of me and almost like
the entire canopy had this,
this moon lamp just turned on and flooded it with light and everything is so
clear.
And we walked all the way back down in his truck with your eyes closed.
I swear to you,
man,
I'll never,
to this day I'm not even,
you know,
it was,
it was an insane and we got,
you only do it once.
One time.
I've never been met anybody that's even heard of it or knew where to find it
since.
But uh,
Brian used get tons of this shit and he does,
he just laid with his headphones on for like eight hours in his living room and
listen to music.
And you're completely,
he's illegal.
Oh,
well I mean to,
to possess it and that kind of quantity.
Yeah.
What you have to have permits and things like that to,
but uh,
we got to the truck and he had a Toyota Tacoma with the bucket seats and a
really nice stereo,
like it's booming,
asked area and he's putting like band of Gypsies or something.
And I laid that bucket seat back,
man and close my eyes.
And within a matter of seconds,
half a minute or a minute,
I wasn't in that truck anymore.
I wasn't in this bucket seat.
I felt like you never floated down river on an inner tube is the same feeling
except seven or two.
I was laying in this little like my own little personal cloud,
just kind of like,
and is it just as I'm sitting here talking to you,
I was in this cloud cruising through this golden Sianna Purple Sunrise Sky,
just like the most booming,
blissful euphoria I've ever felt listening to Jimi Hendrix and this lasted like
six hours,
man.
You're just like cruising through the sky.
Wow.
I've never had that for many of,
you know,
what people commonly associate as hallucinogens or,
um,
that's tough.
Sounds intense.
Yeah.
I talked to doctors trashman buddy said there's not a loan.
There's never really been any studies.
It's not about known your Guinea pigs.
Turtle Simpson,
Human Guinea.
Yeah.
No.
Well,
this was all years and years ago,
man.
I don't know that I'm,
you should do a trip report on Erowid.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Oh,
the forum.
I know you're talking about.
Yeah.
Well that's one of the most,
uh,
important resources Arrow it is for people understanding what,
what they're getting into because there's a lot of really educated,
very,
very like well thought out reviews of the various compounds and different,
different effects.
They have trip reports.
I didn't know anything about it until then and I've never seen it since.
But I do remember the guy saying that the difference in three or four or 200
milligrams is a thousand times stronger trip.
Nobody's ever really documented.
I thousand times stronger trip,
four or 500 milligrams,
you know,
you can.
Wow.
Is there any negative downsides?
Um,
the only thing I remember is I might've had like a slight allergic reaction
because I remember feeling like I had sun poisoning and it was like really
scratching my back.
Kind of tripping out on this for a second.
This is on early onset and the guys were like,
what are you doing?
I was like,
man,
I think I got too much sun today and I'm actually itching.
And,
and uh,
Chad was like,
no,
it's not.
You're fine.
And as soon as he said that,
like the whole sensation went away.
But,
uh,
I didn't have,
I mean it wasn't,
there was nothing negative about the experience.
Then when it's over,
the come down just like just goes away,
back to baseline and just kind of wears off.
Wow.
That's so weird.
You will always wonder like if there was,
if it was easy for people to do research on psychedelics and they,
it was respected
and it was something that people pursued as opposed to being like,
you know,
if you do research on,
on certain things,
you could be thought of as a pariah.
You could,
it could fuck with you.
You know,
you could,
you could be ostracized.
People could say,
oh,
this guy just wants to get high.
He's just trying to get people high.
He's like,
he's just doing some experimental drugs is not doing
serious research where they think there's some hidden agenda or Zillow ruined
it,
right?
Yeah,
it could be.
There's a massive hospital in Lexington,
Kentucky that is called,
is called the narcotics farm.
And it was a,
it was a,
uh,
criminal
institution for,
for drug know.
William Burroughs was there for a while and they did a lot of like highly
barbaric experimental addiction treatments.
They're back in like the forties and 50s and just unspeakable things like
dropping people's genitals and ice water or something like that.
Right.
Like kind of ridiculous approaches to dealing with,
with heroin and Methadone addiction.
And I know they did some psychedelic studies,
I'm sure back there.
But you know,
it's,
the hospital's still stands there and it's just the most ominous,
creepy building.
Methadone is a weird one.
This and that.
It's horrible shit.
They use it to get people off heroin,
but yet it's worse for you than heroin withdrawals are way worse.
Yeah.
How it just makes them well too,
right.
It doesn't get them high.
Is that the deal?
It,
it,
whatever the genetical attachment that you're,
you know,
you're wanting,
heroin is like one of those drugs that actually modifies your bodies,
you know,
biochemistry in a way that you become physically dependent on it.
So they're kind of facilitating that,
whatever it is that causes the sickness.
When you withdraw,
but at the shit it's like it's way worse for you
and it doesn't get you high.
Nobody talks about I really good methadone music,
you know,
like,
yeah,
right.
People did heroin and made some fucking incredible music.
Nobody did.
Methadone made some awesome shit.
There was these guys that used to come to the pool holidays to hang out in white
plains and uh,
they were called the Methadone Ian's,
that's what we would call them.
They would do dudes that came over from the Methadone clinic and they'd come
over and play pool and they were just Zombie Fides just dead in the eyes.
Yeah.
What's his deal?
I just one of those Methadone Ian's,
it's four guys came over from the Methadone clinic.
What do you guys do right here when you got to take a massively,
intensely painful pis?
You got to do it right now.
Go run.
Take a piss.
All right.
We're almost done.
Anyway,
you,
you run and I'll tell everybody how to get to your website.
Sturgill Simpson as he takes his little girl's bladder to the bathroom.
Not everyone can deal with a bulletproof coffee.
And
all that stuff.
Water
just sitting there.
It just ways weighs on.
You have it,
you'll have that sometimes.
Yeah,
occasionally.
Yeah.
But I get it occasionally too,
man.
It definitely does happen.
Uh,
Sturgis website.
His Twitter is Sturgill Simpson.
Um,
and if you go to it,
it's a actually that image that,
um,
the,
uh,
the image of the earth sands,
the turtles underneath it,
similar image,
but sturgeon is,
uh,
the cds that I have a mom.
Like I said,
I'm a big fucking fan.
He's got,
uh,
several songs and I'm really into that.
I'm listening to right now on iTunes.
Um,
but the cds,
let me find them on my playlist here.
Met a modern sounds and country.
That's a,
that's the name of one.
That's the latest one.
That's the one that's the most psychedelic.
And then the other one is a high top mountain,
which is fucking fantastic.
I really,
really dig it.
Um,
they're very different,
but both of them are equally equally a unique and kick ass.
I love all of it.
I'm sure he's got a website too.
Must be like Sturgill simpson.com.
Right.
Check this out.
His website,
sort of Colorado health officials when a band,
almost all recreational edibles pussies.
Really?
Wow.
Sturgill simpson.com is his website.
That's ridiculous.
We just reading something on Huffington Post that they,
health officials in Colorado want to ban all edibles because kids are getting
into him and shit.
Stare just nerf in the world.
That's all they're doing.
They're just nerf in the world.
Really sensationalist piece about this on some national media news program.
Either night because children were Halloween in a hold of them and having
overdoses.
There's no,
it's really scary.
You're gonna like outlook Clorox too.
Cause your kids going under the fucking sink and you're doing a bad parent.
I mean Cox is way worse first of all.
Right?
Cause the kids that are having the overdose on Pod,
they're not dying.
Well they might freak out,
but they're not going to die.
It does.
It's not toxic,
right.
It just doesn't,
you don't anything they can fuck your kids up.
Just don't let them get to it,
you know?
Yeah.
Don't let your kid play with hammers.
You know,
shouldn't fucking go to home depot and shut it down stupid and take away spoons.
The idea that adults,
a grown adult should not be able to buy an edible that has a clearly marked
label.
All these experiences that we're talking about,
like you ate this little thing was the size of a nickel.
You got fucked up.
You learn,
you learn,
you're here,
everyone's fine.
It's like the lowest worry version of overdose ever.
Cause the overdoses just,
well,
I say overdose.
It's still,
I mean all it means is I'm going to go lay in bed and having a really good time
instead of walking around and having a really good time,
but there's no ill effects that will affect your body doesn't break.
Your mind doesn't melt.
You're going to be fine.
At the end of the day,
you might just get a really great night's sleep.
Yeah,
I'm not really recommended and you give it to your kids,
but he did get ahold of it.
Just stay with them.
Just keep stay in the room with them.
Everybody's going to be okay.
Two deaths,
two to them,
but I don't ever want somebody one and fell out of
a off of a hotel.
And the other guy,
it says,
Richard Kirk may have been on pain meds in a palatable when he killed his wife.
Pain meds are guarantee.
I would go with that.
The pot add a bill would have probably cause it was pot out of bowl was probably
wrestling with the pain and beds as he was grabbing hold of the trigger.
Fuck,
fuck all that man.
You can't blame a guy falling off a roof on pot.
What are you doing on the roof?
Stupid Pot didn't tell you to get up on that roof.
Why'd you fall off that roof?
You know he probably would have fell off that roof no matter what he was on.
You can't fuck around on rooves dummy.
Especially when you're blitzed.
That's a silly idea.
Who knows what he was doing.
But to blame that on pot is fucking stupid.
Instead of blaming that on pot.
How about you think about how many fucking people don't jump off the roof when
they're on pot?
It's like a lot more.
It also says that,
uh,
the cookie hate didn't give him the recommended immediate effect that he wanted.
So then he ate six times the recommended dose.
Silly Bitch.
You can,
you can fucking corner,
you know,
rest in peace.
Silly Bitch.
You're like,
people make mistakes,
man.
You can't blame the substance.
I mean it's like what are we going to do?
We're going to outlaw cars because people get in accidents are we gonna outlawed
knives cause people stab people.
The idea that adults can't make their own decisions has been the folly of man
since civilization was created.
We have to figure out what decisions are the right ones,
educate each other and then move forward from there.
But to tell someone that they can handle it because Jim over here jumped off the
fucking roof.
Everybody,
while those positive experiences that he had eaten pot,
we're going to flush those down the toilet because we lost Jim.
Okay.
Jim is a wild man.
Jim was fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Jim used to walk a tight rope and he,
you know,
he used to do a fucking back flips off the garage,
but whatever.
We loved him and he's gone.
So no more pot for everybody.
Be like,
what are you talking about?
I mean we get an outlaw guns every time someone commit suicide are we?
What are we going to do?
What kind of a goofy world and we're going to create,
because if you just make everything illegal,
everything that kills you is going to be illegal.
You're going to have nothing.
You're going to have no electricity.
There'll be no water because people could fucking drown.
They'll be no food because sometimes food goes bad and people die of food
poisoning.
There'll be everything going to take away everything you,
you literally,
if you want to take away things that kill people,
you literally have to remove life itself.
No more dogs because dogs bite people no more spiders cause we got to skin
pores.
You were going to have to poison all the spiders because they can poison people,
but we can't have spider poison because that kills babies if they get out of it
under the sink,
so we'll have no life.
There will be no life.
It's just preposterous.
And the idea that how Colorado is going to step in and legislate that,
well we need to do is get all of those fucking people,
hi.
Where is that coming from?
Or what some Tommy's,
yeah.
What's,
what's the issue?
Like they're worried about people freaking out on edibles and that's all it is.
Is so strong.
Yeah,
but so what?
Don't need as much lower the dose.
You know what's really strong alcohol?
It's everywhere.
Go to a fucking store,
drink a bottle of Jack Daniels.
You're dead.
You're dead in three hours or whatever it takes.
You know,
maybe you've got a better tolerance than me,
but if you eat a fucking,
you know,
you drink a gallon jug of Jack Daniels,
most likely you're a goner.
It's uh,
it's really,
yeah,
that's,
there's some truth there.
I used to really drink at all anymore was just trying to think.
Most of that is probably related to my job,
cause he spend,
you spend night after night looking at rooms full of people that are very drunk
and it,
it,
it gives you a certain,
I don't know.
Plus looking back on my life,
all the dumbest shit I ever did.
Alcohol was pretty much directly related.
You know,
all of it.
The worst decisions I ever made.
It wasn't because I was on hard drugs.
I was like,
you know,
go figure.
No,
it's,
it's the number one sanction drug.
I mean,
it's what everybody does to have a good time after work.
Let's Kava drink.
I'm not opposed to having a drink.
I like having a drink.
I really do.
I like drinking.
I don't drink too much.
I don't get fucked up,
but I've been fucked up and I've had a great time,
you know?
Yeah.
It's bad for you.
But so it was a lot.
There's really nothing worse than a drunk.
Very few things.
Very obnoxious.
Trusting them.
Noxious.
Strong.
Yeah.
Especially a violent,
obnoxious trunk.
It's the worst.
The worst is you ever been on a date with a girl and you're sober and she's
drunk.
That's disastrous.
Really.
Drunk girls are the worst.
Really drunk guys.
The worst.
They're the worst.
I think really drunk guys have the worst cause.
They're more violent than the really drunk girls.
You know?
Those are the,
is it said at the shows are the,
they're the only ones that ever want to talk to me.
Like the,
the other guys in the van are young and they get hit on other girls and girls
never want to talk to sturgeon.
Me,
that's always like the really big,
like large drunk guy and they all like,
give me the bear hug and I get the Wayland and then there's just like hugging me
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm limitating off the ground and they're giving me like this thing like fucking
man shit.
That one song,
man.
Damn Dude.
Uh,
and those are the only people that I want to talk to me.
You're like the really huge,
like Wilbur beast drunk really redneck guys.
That's my curse.
Yay.
They're fun to talk to them.
They're fucking great.
Have a good time.
Talking to a lot of those dudes.
I do,
I'd say,
I think this is a certain romance and fun involved in alcohol consumption that I
embrace.
I,
it's not the end all be all,
but it's not bad.
It's some fun to alcohol,
you know?
It's an irresponsible,
oftentimes reckless,
stupid,
impulsive feeling and state of mind.
But with the right people,
that shit works.
You know?
It's just,
it's bad for your health as the new,
a lot of people when they shouldn't,
that shouldn't smoke pot.
Fuck yeah.
Thing hits people differently.
Yeah.
I know a lot of people that shouldn't drink though.
A lot more people that shouldn't drink and shouldn't do anything else.
I know friends that,
I have friends that smoked pot,
I can't drink it.
They're alcoholics,
but they'll still smoke pot so they don't drink well,
well it's not even so,
but they can,
they can smoke pot and they're fine,
but if they drink,
they're off the rails.
The G,
yeah,
that weird lot Irishman.
A lot of that,
that weird gene gene.
It's just,
hey,
just hits them like a truck.
They can't do it.
They can't regulate.
It takes over.
Whoa.
I mean we were,
we were in Ireland a couple of weeks ago and there you talking about some
fucking savages.
Great people though.
Me.
Oh yeah.
Just
if all the places in Great Britain or Europe that we've played,
it's the,
it feels the most like the states cause they're just like,
you know,
and a lot of the British and the Scottish audiences are so intensely attentive
and appreciative and it's almost disconcertingly quiet when you get to Ireland,
there's like,
you're like,
Yep,
okay.
Done this before.
They like American country music.
They fucking love it,
man.
That's a Scottish and the Irish,
especially when it all came from there.
Really?
Yeah.
All country,
bluegrass,
anything.
It's all just a derivative of,
of,
of Scotch Irish folk music that came over with the settlers.
We just kinda no shit,
drink whiskey and sit on the porch for a hundred years and he just got faster
and faster.
Traditional Irish music and a lot of Scottish fiddle tunes.
Um,
like the Mandolin is tune in d uh,
like,
just like a bagpipe because of the wound,
the pipes got out law,
they started playing a lot of those songs on stringed instruments.
Wow.
Why did the pipes get out?
La?
No,
four.
Basically it was their diversion.
There's the British equivalent of the,
the law against inciting a riot.
You know,
like somebody pulled out some fucking bagpipes back in the day,
like some shit is going to go down,
man.
So wow.
They made a law against Bagpipe.
Yeah,
they outlawed them.
How long?
I don't know.
Like years.
Yeah,
Jamie.
All of that tradition kind of came over and that a lot of,
it's where a lot of country music,
the melodies and the themes and the elements of that,
they're very similar.
Is that why like that,
Lord of the dance shit,
like when they were still dancing a little bit like line dancing.
Yeah.
Well isn't it?
That's a little questionable.
I don't know.
We'll go,
what Michael was the fuck was his name?
The Lord of the dance flat.
Flatly.
That was short lived people like,
yeah,
let's go Irish dancing.
No,
it's not.
I did it for a little while.
He still actually,
I think I saw a fucking billboard for it when I was a few suckers left in town.
Man
was,
most people got hip to that and went,
hey wait,
wait,
wait.
What the fuck are we watch it?
What does that do?
Do it up there,
man.
That was weird.
Yeah.
But yeah,
it's all,
it's all interconnected.
That's amazing.
I really,
really do.
Really s man especially I've in Glasgow and Dublin and we feel like we've almost
been adopted at this point.
Really.
They just,
they're so appreciative.
How often you play over there?
I've been over five or six times this year.
No Shit.
Yeah.
Actually we're,
we haven't really started our us tour on the album.
He came back in May,
but I spent the majority of the year in Europe.
Wow.
Why is
that?
It's just,
I,
it's important.
It was always important to me to,
to go there and play for those people.
And why?
I don't know,
just free travel really,
man.
And plus you get the fucking play music every night and see Europe and I think,
I honestly will hear careers can be such,
it's a little,
it has a potential to be a little bit more flash in the pan base over here.
People get bored quicker.
But,
uh,
I've just had a lot of friends that are musicians that said,
if you make the effort and you go over and they see you,
they see you taking the trouble in time to come over.
Like they're,
they're loyal.
They're just fans for life.
I'll probably still be touring over there long after any career I have here.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
What about,
is that England as well?
So much,
I mean there's a market but it,
it appears to be sincerely and genuinely appreciated in the Celtic areas.
Dublin and Belfast and Glasgow and Edinburgh and uh,
you know,
these,
these are really very musical cities at their core,
but they just,
you know,
anything poetry related or you know,
storytelling,
they just really love it.
How upset were they that youtube put their songs on every iPhone where they
bummed out?
I don't know.
It was Dublin pissed.
They've gone soft.
I go out of my way to a stay as much the fuck out of their business as possible
and I'm there.
Right.
You know,
just show up and do my job because it's always,
you know.
Do you know the story about youtube putting their youtube,
put their new album on every iPhone.
The other day I'm in my car and starts playing random and all of sudden I got
some youtube,
oops,
I'm sorry.
Bondo apologizes for you to the album be automatically added to apple iTunes
live.
Now that you say that,
man,
I was backstage yesterday sinking my phone up to to a new laptop.
I got on the road and I was getting all the clouds shit and I looked down there
was a fucking youtube album.
Exactly.
Okay.
I was wondering why is this here?
Yeah,
why is that there?
I don't want that.
I'm in my car the other day and I had my car plugged in.
I got the thing,
you know the plugs into the stereo system.
It's playing random.
I just do it that sometimes.
So they monopolize the iTunes basically while they figured out a way to launch
their album on iTunes.
But the problem is a lot of people that buy an iPhone aren't you two fans.
It's a fucking very presumptuous thing.
And you're dealing with billions of these fucking things being sold.
So how many of them have you two songs on them?
All of them.
I mean how many of their selling and you mean they might sell 100 million
iPhones,
right?
That's all with a u two album on it.
That's stupid.
That's not how many youtube would sell.
Youtube is a very popular band.
I'm sure a lot of people would be super happy to get you to song for free with
the new iPhone.
But a lot of people with them,
they pushed him under the existing funds.
Yes,
I had a five s Oh really?
To show that.
Oh No.
So when you update the operating system,
not even that.
No showed up what their iTunes?
No,
just showed up this dirty,
even dirty already purchased it and you just didn't download it yet.
Showed up.
That's,
that's actually discussed.
That's a disaster.
That's why he's had,
sorry.
Why did he let that go?
I read the other day [inaudible] he also said that,
uh,
he's been wearing those fucking classes for 20 years cause he's got glaucoma.
Do you buy that?
You look a little incredulous.
Yup.
The jury's out.
Jury's out.
I wonder he's probably got called on it and you know,
people are like,
hey man,
why is it just now coming up though?
I mean people have been wondering what the fuck.
I mean remember he had like the fly these big,
the big black ones back in the day.
Like everybody just let that shit slide.
Like nobody was like,
hey man,
what the fuck?
I wonder if he smokes weed.
Cause if you have glaucoma you're allowed to reduce,
reduces interocular pressure.
It's one of the legit reasons to get a medical marijuana prescription.
My grandfather has really bad glaucoma now,
but he's never,
I would never,
I don't even know how I would approach that conversation with him.
We'd,
Oh yeah,
he's such an old school,
like just a hillbilly,
you know?
Right.
Just never,
never,
you know,
I don't even know how I would convince him that this actually will make you feel
better.
Just sit them down,
you know?
Um,
set them down.
Yeah.
Get him drunk first.
Andrew Hayes,
he's pretty,
pretty stoic guy.
Got me.
Well then just sit them down.
Maybe I just don't tell him.
Just give him the brownies and I freak out and have a heart attack and die.
Well that would be very bad.
Yes.
Sit them down.
All right.
I'll send it down.
You're a grown man now my off to go home and actually see you,
but listen man,
we're out of time.
We just did ran through three hours.
Really?
Yup.
Holy Shit.
Crazy right?
That's nuts.
Time flies.
It all just slips away.
I tell people a your website Sturgill simpson.com.
Um,
your,
your two albums,
uh,
you could get them on iTunes and I listed them off while you were taking a leak.
If anybody's interested,
you got to,
I mean,
my favorite songs,
I,
there's a bunch of them.
You can have the crown.
I fucking love that off your first one.
That's a great fucking,
why are you laughing?
Oh Man.
It's nothing what it,
it's,
it's that.
It's that song.
Everybody's got that song.
They wish they never wrote a song.
That song's great.
Yeah,
I fucking love that.
So there's a lot of fun and I had an,
I wrote it in about 20 minutes to like seven 30 in the morning and we ended up
recording it that day.
We just happened to go into the studio,
actually Wayland's old studio in Nashville.
He'll be central.
We got the opportunity to record in there and Dave was like,
what are you guys new?
And I'd written that song and another song literally that morning before I knew
we were going to be in there.
I was like,
well I,
so I played it for him and the rest of the guys of course there is laughing
their ass off and you're like,
we've got to cut that.
So we cut it and then I heard that the of the day I heard the playback and I'm
like,
I'm going to be singing that fucking thing when I'm 60 years old.
I was going to be the one and sure as shit man,
every show,
every fucking show,
uh,
the,
it never fails.
There's that one guy and in between every song came tire mother tired.
You know,
there's these,
any like he follows us.
It has to be the same guy.
I don't know.
What will you start off with songs saying I spent all my money on weed and
pills.
Yeah,
that's,
that's how it launches.
You got,
you got to get both albums folks there.
They're both very different,
which I thought was really fascinating too,
before I got to meet you and understand what it's from.
Uh,
what,
what caused it.
Um,
and then the other one met a modern,
met a modern sounds in country music.
I love that too,
man.
Thank you dude.
You're the shit.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for being you.
Thanks for being on here.
And please consider you for telling you about it.
Yeah,
that's the Internet man.
The Internet knows all.
It's fucking scary.
All right.
You dirty bitches.
We'll see you soon.
This week.
Lot a lot of podcasts including that lady sue from a life below zero.
Very excited to talk to her.
Cameron Hanes is here on Friday too.
Awesome.